in this project-based course you will
learn how to build AI powered apps with
the chat GPT Dolly and gpt4 apis Tom
chant developed this course Tom is a
front-end developer and course creator
with scrimba hey there free code compass
and welcome to this interactive course
where you are going to build
mind-blowing ai-powered applications
with features that didn't seem possible
even just a few months ago we'll be
starting with the very Basics so you
don't need any previous knowledge of the
open AI API in fact the only
prerequisites for this course are basic
vanilla JavaScript and some curiosity
now the special thing about this course
is that it's Project based and it comes
with a ton of challenges and that means
you're going to have your hands on the
keyboard writing code and tackling
challenges throughout and if you're
wondering how you can get your hands on
the project code don't worry we've got
you covered in the interactive version
of this course over on scrimber you can
pause the video edit the code and run
the projects right there in your browser
or if you prefer you can download the
code from those scrims and run the
projects locally the link is right down
there in the description oh one last
thing before we start if you enjoyed
this course please hit that thumbs up
right here on YouTube that will be much
appreciated and if you'd like to get in
touch reach out to me on Twitter I am at
TP chant okay let's get started
welcome to building AI apps with chat
GPT Dali and gpt4 I am super excited to
bring you this course on the technology
everybody is talking about we are going
to study how to use the open AI API
we'll be using various open AI models
including the latest gpt4 model we'll be
looking at prompt engineering we'll be
building chat Bots and we'll be
fine-tuning a model on our own data and
along the way of course there will be
lots more and plenty of challenges
now I need to say a quick word about
gpt4 we'll be using the gpt4 API in the
second project in this course now at
present there is a waiting list to get
your hands on the API no doubt in the
near future the wait list will go and
the API will be available to everybody
but for now while the wait list exists
why not click on this screenshot which
will take you through to the sign up
page and you can join the waiting list
there if it still exists okay so what
are we going to build we'll start off by
exploiting the power of openai to be
creative and generate human standard
words and images to build this cool
movie Pitch app which turns a one
sentence idea into a full movie outline
then we'll use the gpt4 model to create
an ask me anything chat bot called know
it all and we'll use a Google Firebase
database so the user can persist the
conversation they have with the chat bot
and pick it up at a to date after
refreshing the browser lastly we're
going to stay with the chatbot concept
but under the hood everything will be
different we will enter the world of
fine tuning this is where we upload our
own data set and we create a chat bot
that can answer specific questions from
our own data this skill is really
essential if you want to use a chat bot
for a specific purpose such as to handle
customer service issues with your
company and with this project we'll also
learn a really neat skill for whenever
you're working with apis with secret
Keys we'll look at deploying the site
with netlify with the API key hidden so
you can share your project without fear
of the API key being compromised this
solves the really big problem that we
have when we're using apis with secret
keys in front end projects
now there are not too many prerequisites
for this course we're going to be
working in vanilla JavaScript and I'll
assume you have a reasonable knowledge
of it now the JavaScript in this isn't
very complicated for the most part as
long as you understand the basics of a
fetch request you'll be absolutely fine
and if you're Rusty on fetch requests
don't worry at all we'll actually go
through it all step by step and I don't
think you'll have a problem apart from
that we'll be focusing fully on the AI
and working through it stage by stage
who am I my name is Tom chant and I'll
be your tutor for this course you can
find me on Twitter my handle is at TP
chant and it's always good to hear how
you got on with the course
now before you get started why don't you
head over to scrimba's Discord server
and go to the today I will Channel and
let the community know that you're
starting this course studying is more
fun and more productive when it's done
together so why not interact with fellow
students on the Discord Community
encourage each other and help each other
along and then without further Ado let's
jump straight in to the first project
in 2006 Terry russio and Bill Marcelli
sold the rights to the Denzel Washington
film Deja Vu for a record-breaking 5
million dollars and it went on to gross
more than 180 million dollars worldwide
have you ever dreamed of making it big
in the movies coming up with that one
idea that will make you rich Beyond Your
Wildest Dreams well the most successful
projects start with one single idea but
once you've had that idea you need to
work with it brainstorm around it spend
hour upon hour working late into the
night to forge it into something
marketable or do you what if you could
take one simple idea just a single
sentence and let the power of open ai's
large language model do the rest of the
work for you well what used to be
science fiction is now science fact this
is movie Pitch and on the outside it is
so simple we put a one sentence idea for
a movie in here we click Send and that
is all we have to do we sit back and we
wait for maybe 10 seconds or 15 seconds
and then what we get back when openai
has done its thing is the makings of a
great movie we get some artwork for the
cover a great title and a list of stars
and most importantly of all we get these
synopsis that brings the idea to life
and all of this is brought To Us by The
Power of openai Now to get this app
working we have got some work to do so
what will we be studying well we will be
using the open AI API we'll be working
with models and understanding what
tokens are we'll learn about crafting
prompts and how to tweak those prompts
to get results and how we can use
examples to train the model we'll be
looking at extracting information from
texts and also generating images just
with words and by the end of all that
we'll have a great foundation in how to
use open AI in front end projects now I
want to give you a warning as we build
this project the API key for open AI
will be sat there on the front end and
that means it's visible anybody could go
in through devtools to the network Tab
and they could steal your API key now
while you're developing locally that is
fine but don't share your project with
an API key or publish it to GitHub
without ignoring the API key because
that will compromise the API key now
later in this course but not in this
project we're going to look at how we
can deploy our apps with the API Keys
safely stored on a server where no one
else can see it but in the meantime just
be mindful of what you're doing with
your API key okay so when you're ready
let's jump into the code and check out
the HTML and CSS that I've got waiting
for you
so let's have a look at the code that
we've already got and then we'll get
straight on to the AI so here in
index.html there's nothing particularly
strange or unusual going on I've brought
in a couple of Google fonts we've got
Playfair and pop-ins and then down in
the body we've got a header section
which has just got the movie Pitch logo
that you can see right here and then
underneath that we've got a main and
that is divided up into two sections
this first section here is all about the
setup and that is everything that you
can see right here so this is where we
collect the user's idea with this text
area and we interact with the movie boss
and you can see that we've got his
speech bubble right here with this
rather braggadocious statement that
we've actually got hard coded right here
in the HTML now the second section that
we've got down here this is dedicated to
the output this is where we'll actually
display the finished product that the AI
creates for us now we can't see that
section in the mini browser at the
moment because if we have a look at the
CSS it's actually set to display none so
we'll bring that into view when we're
ready for it now sticking with the CSS
we've got a bunch of styles in here it's
really unlikely that there's anything
particularly new or strange but by all
means feel free to pause and familiarize
yourself with it to be honest we won't
be referring to it that much as the
course goes on we'll just touch on it
now and again as we need to now over in
index.js we have already got a little
bit of JavaScript I've taken control of
the three elements that we're actually
working with already so we've got the
text area which we've already seen down
here the setup input container that is
the container for the text area and the
button and then we've also taken control
of the movie boss text and that is what
you can see right here inside this
speech bubble now we've got an event
listener and it's listening out for
clicks on this button and when it
detects a click it does a couple of
things firstly it checks if there's
anything inside the text area right here
if there isn't it does nothing if there
is it will replace this text area and
this button with a loading GIF and we're
just bringing that in right here from
the images folder and also it will
update the speech bubble with some new
text this is actually hard coded into
the JavaScript and that is actually the
last bit of human written text that
you're going to see for a while from
this point onwards will mostly be
working with AI generated text let's
just put something in that text area and
check it's working
so there's my one sentence idea for a
movie an evil genius wants to take over
the world with AI and only one Brave
Mouse can stop him let's hit send and as
soon as we do that we get this loading
SVG just to communicate to the user that
something is happening and we've updated
the speech bubble just wait a second
while my digital brain digests that okay
so everything is working as we want it
to and the next thing we need to do is
start applying some AI to this we want
to actually get an AI generated response
to our idea but before we take the first
step into this mystical and magical
world of AI we need to talk about some
more mundane matters like how we can
actually access the open AI API from
within our app that's how we'll get our
hands on these Powers so let's come on
to that next
let's get our hands on an open AI API
key and that means signing up so why
don't you head over to the open AI home
page and this slide is actually a
clickable link so if you just click on
the screenshot it will take you straight
there now when you're there just pause
for a moment to check out some of these
really beautiful images that they've
created with their Dali image generation
model and we will be looking at image
generation later in this course now once
you've feasted your eyes on the pictures
head over to where it says API and from
there you'll need to go to sign up and
then you can choose your sign up method
and you'll need to confirm with a phone
number now once you're in from the
dashboard you can click your avatar up
here and select view API Keys now they
only show you the API key once when it's
first generated after that it will be
obscured like this so be sure to copy
and paste it somewhere safe as soon as
you get it but if you lose it don't
worry from here you can actually delete
it and get a new one and like all API
Keys be sure to keep it secret in this
project we're building you will see my
API key but rest assured that by the
time this recording goes public I will
have deleted it okay so that's the API
key now while we're here let's just say
a quick word about credit if we click on
the usage here it will take us through
to a page where we can see how much
credit we've got remaining now at the
time of recording when you sign up you
get some free credit to play with I got
18 of credit which was valid for three
months and it actually looks like I'm
nearly through that but I have been a
heavy user so you'll probably find that
the free credit you get will get you a
very long way now when that credit has
expired or been used up it is a
pay-as-you-go model check the website
for the latest info on that okay now
let's take our API key and build our
first Quest when you're ready for that
let's move on
now we've got our API key we can start
using the API but before we can make our
first fetch request we need an API
endpoint let's head back to the openai
website and click through to the docs
and this slide is a clickable link of
course and it will take you straight
there now the open AI docs are pretty
comprehensive and right here on the
first page it tells us that the
completions endpoint is at the center of
our API okay that sounds interesting the
completions endpoint we're going to
check it out but before we do that you
might well be asking what is a
completion and completion is a word used
a lot in open AI so let's say you want
some information like you want to know
who the first person to walk on the moon
was let's send that question to open AI
via the API and it will think about it
and send back a completion and that
completion is of course Neil Armstrong
so in the world of open AI a completion
is a response from the API AI that
fulfills your request okay let's click
through to the completions endpoint
section in the docs and here we get a
ton of info and some code examples and
each example is given in node.js PHP and
curl but what I want to focus on is this
we have the completions API endpoint
right here and it tells us we can use
the post method
so now we've got that info let's come
back to index.js and I'm going to save
it in a const called URL
and in the next scrim let's start
writing a fetch request
let's start this API call by laying out
the bare bones of the fetch request so
we need fetch
and then we open up the brackets and we
pass in the completions endpoint and
we've got that saved here as URL now we
need an object and inside this object
we're going to need method headers and
body and if we check back with the docs
we know that the method is post it tells
us that right here next to the endpoint
now the docs don't actually give us an
example fetch request in JavaScript but
they do give us this curl example and we
can adapt it so let's take a closer look
our headers are going to need a content
type of application Json and will also
need an authorization of Bearer with our
API key so let's go ahead and put those
in
okay now we need a body and this is
where we get into open AI specifics the
body for an open AI request needs a
model and a prompt so I'll come down
here and add the body
and then I'm going to say json.stringify
and I'll pass in an object with model
and prompt
now if we look back at this screenshot
it actually gives us a model right here
text
davinci-003 so let's break the golden
rule of coding and just copy a line of
code that we don't actually understand
we haven't discussed what open AI models
actually are or what options we have
available to us yet but what I want to
do is get this example working get the
first API request actually into our app
and then we'll rewind and talk about
models in more detail for now just know
that openai has got various models that
we can use and today we're going to use
this one called text DaVinci 003 okay so
I'll put that in a string right here
Okay so we've got the model and now we
need the prompt and we're going to talk
about prompts a lot in this course but
for now what we need to know is this in
this example that we saw in the previous
scrim we asked a question who was the
first person to walk on the moon and we
got the completion Neil Armstrong well
the prompt is this part who was the
first person to walk on the moon the
prompt is whatever we ask the open AI
API for now sometimes prompts are really
really simple just like this and
sometimes they're really very complex as
you'll see a bit later in this course
now they've given us an example prompt
in the docs say this is a test which to
be honest is not very creative so
instead of using that I'm going to ask
an easy but real world question for this
prompt I'm just going to say what is the
capital of Spain
and that is all we need to do for a
simple prompt we just put it in a string
okay now we need to change some vents
so we'll take the response and we'll
call Jason on it
and then we'll take the data from that
response and log it out
okay let's open up the console and I'll
hit save and we've run into an error
it's a pretty silly one it's just a typo
on my part but why don't you just pause
now and see if you can debug that and
I'll give you a bit of a clue have a
quick look at this slide
okay did you spot it I've actually put
Bearer colon and then the API key I
think that is causing the problem let's
try it one more time and there we are
we're getting a response so I'm just
going to copy this from the console and
paste it in the editor just so we can
see it a little bit more easily
and as we can see this is an object it's
got loads of data in it and we'll be
talking more about some of the
properties in this object as we go along
but for now we just need to focus on one
word
Madrid because that shows us it works
open AI is speaking to us and it knows
all about Spain now okay knowing facts
is great but we're actually interested
in emotion and creativity so I'm
actually just going to change things a
little bit let's delete this and I'm
going to change my prompt to say
something more emotional
I've said sound sympathetic in five
words or less let's hit save
and again I'll just paste the response
right here and look what we've got I'm
here for you it's giving us sympathy and
what's really cool about that is that
now the AI is speaking to us as if it
were human it's speaking with heartfelt
or at least CPU felt emotion and that is
what we're looking for okay let's take
what we've got here and apply it to our
project and I haven't forgotten this
model that we've got here text DaVinci
003 it's still shrouded in mystery but I
want you to get your hands on the
keyboard start getting practice start
building muscle memory before I do any
more talking so let's move on to a
challenge with this next
okay so back in our app we've got an
event listener right here and it's
listening out for clicks on this button
and what it does is it checks to see if
the user has given us any input it
displays a loading message and updates
the text that we see in the speech
bubble right here now we're not ready to
work with any user inputted text yet so
I'm actually just going to comment out
this if and if I save that now this code
should run as soon as we click this
button and there we are we get our
loader and we've updated the text that
we've got in the speech bubble so let's
go ahead and make an API call to get an
enthusiastic response that we can pass
to our user and of course later we'll
refactor this so the AI is actually
responding to the specific idea that the
user gave us but for now the response we
get back from the AI is just going to be
generic so I'm going to call a function
in here called Fetch bot reply and then
I'll come down here and I'll do the
donkey work of setting up the skeleton
of this function and now it's over to
you here's a challenge to finish off
this function and I'm just going to
paste it right here inside the function
body because that is where I want you to
write code
so your challenge is this I want you to
make a fetch request to the openai API
and I've put all of the details that you
need up here so you'll have to put your
own API key in here and this is the URL
to the endpoint now the prompt should
request an enthusiastic response in no
more than five words and you know how to
do that because in the previous scrim we
did exactly the same thing to get a
sympathetic response for now you can
just log out the completion to check
it's working now before you start there
are two things I want to say the first
is if what you get from the completion
isn't quite what you wanted or what you
expected don't worry we're going to talk
a lot more about using prompts and
troubleshooting the issues that you can
have the purpose of this challenge is
just to get the syntax right so we are
actually getting a completion back from
open AI secondly by all means go back to
the previous scrims just to have a look
at the syntax that we need but don't
copy and paste you're going to do
yourself a lot of favors by writing this
out by hand all of that practice just
builds muscle memory and builds up your
fluency okay pause now get this
challenge sorted and I'll see you back
here in just a minute
foreign
so
what we need to do then is come in here
and set up a fetch request
and we'll pass in the URL that we've got
stored right here and then we'll open up
the object and we know that the method
is post
and then we need the headers
and that will be an object with two key
value pairs the first is the content
type which will be application Json
and the second will be authorization and
that will be a string with the word
Bearer and our API key
then we need the body and the body is
going to need a model and a prompt
so firstly we say json.stringify
and then we pass in an object with model
text DaVinci 003
and prompt
and for my prompt I'm going to say sound
enthusiastic in five words or less
because that is what we want the movie
boss to do we want him to sound
enthusiastic
okay let's change some vents so we can
deal with the response
somebody called Jason on the response
and then we'll take the data from that
response and log it out
okay let's hit save and to fire up this
function all we need to do is hit the
send button
and we've got the loading SVG and if I
open up the console there we are it
looks like we've got our completion
let's just copy and paste that into the
editor
and we can see we've got these two words
right here excitedly enthusiastic so
it's taken our prompt very very
literally now the next thing that I want
to do is actually get this completion to
appear inside the speech bubble
so I'm just going to delete this
challenge text so we've got a little bit
more room to work with now we've already
taken control of the text in the speech
bubble we've got the elements stored up
here in this const movie boss text so
let's come down here and instead of
logging something out I'm going to come
onto a new line
and I'll say movieboss.txt dot inner
text
and now we need to access our completion
and we've got that right here so to get
that we need to say data dot choices
and choices holds an array and we
actually want what is in the first
element of the array at position zero
and then we want to access the text
property
okay let's hit save and again I'm just
going to hit this button
and there we are it says eager and
excited in the speech bubble now we've
got a little bit of a problem in that
our design is kind of broken because the
CSS can't really cope with such a short
sentence or that's what it seems at the
moment now I'm not too worried about
that because this sentence is not going
to stay short soon we're actually going
to refactor this function and what we'll
get will be a longer completion which is
actually going to be relevant to the one
line input that the user puts right here
but before we come on to that there are
one or two things that I want to cover
firstly these fetch requests are
unnecessarily complex and long so
instead of writing out loads of these in
our app we can actually use open ai's
dependency and that is going to save us
a lot of work as we move forwards but
before we do that we need to talk about
models because we have used text DaVinci
003 and we haven't really got a handle
on what that means yet so let's come on
to that next
so in the last two scrims we have used
text DaVinci 003 as our model so now
let's ask the question what is an AI
model well Loosely speaking an AI model
is an algorithm that uses training data
to recognize patterns and make
predictions or decisions now openai has
got various models geared towards
different tasks and some models are
newer and therefore better than others
at the moment there are two main
categories of models that you might come
across there's the gpt3 GPT 3.5 and gpt4
models and gpt4 is actually just coming
out right now it's currently in beta and
these models are all about understanding
and generating natural language and they
can also generate computer languages as
well now there's also the Codex models
these models are specifically designed
to generate computer code including
translating natural language to computer
code and vice versa and you've probably
seen examples of that online even if you
haven't tried it yet yourself
open AI also has a model that filters
content to remove or flag unsafe or
sensitive text in this project we'll be
using the text DaVinci 003 model which
is a GPT 3.5 model now this is one of
the newest models it can provide long
text output and its rate of following
instructions there's gpt4 which is fresh
out and we will be coming to that later
in this course there's the text Curie
001 model and this is a very capable
model it's actually faster than text
DaVinci 003 but it's not as good overall
in terms of the language it creates
there's text babbage001 which is great
for straightforward tasks and is also
very very fast and then there's text
ada001 and that is fine for basic tasks
and it's fast and cheap now these models
are in age order so text DaVinci 003 is
the newest on this list
textada001 is the oldest and the older
the models get at the less complex they
are so they run faster and generally
speaking they're cheaper but you should
check the open AI docs for the latest
prices now the Curie Babbage and Ada
models all provide shorter outputs than
text DaVinci 003 but they might well
still be capable of some or even all of
the tasks you might want to do in a
project it depends what it is you want
to achieve but just remember with the
older models being cheaper that means
you can scale apps without incurring too
many costs and because they're faster
you'll experience less of the horrible
laggy ux you can sometimes get when
you're working with any API but
particularly with artificial
intelligence as it obviously has to do
so much computation now so far our app
hasn't been too laggy we've just been
generating quite short quick completions
but as our requests get more complex we
will see lag times increase and now you
might well be asking what model should I
use in my project well open ai's advice
is this start with the best available
model and downgrade to save time and
costs where possible so basically get
your app working so you're happy with
its performance and then experiment with
cheaper models to see if you can get the
same level of results now as new models
come out prices will change and probably
performance will increase on those new
models so you will have to do some
experimentation now to help you with
that in the next Grim I want to
introduce you to a couple of really
useful tools and one of those tools will
help you select the best model when you
come to build your own projects let's
move on to that next
I want to show you a couple of really
useful tools that can help us work with
openai the first one is particularly
useful for model selection this
screenshot is from gpttools.com and this
is their prompt compare tool and of
course this slide is a clickable link
which will take you through to their
site now to use this tool you put your
API key in right here and then it allows
you to set up two API calls side by side
using different models so let's just ask
open AI for a description of Pablo
Picasso's artistic style and there we
are I've put the same prompt on each
side now for the first one I'll use the
model or engine as they call it here of
text DaVinci 003 which is the same as
we're using in our app and for the
second one I'll use text query 001 which
is one of the older models now down here
underneath we've got plenty of other
settings but I'm going to leave them all
at their defaults it will be the same on
both sides so now we can submit and see
the results the first one to come back
is the query which figures the older
simpler models are faster then we get
back DaVinci the big thing that we
notice is that the texts are vastly
differing in length the newer model The
Da Vinci gives us way more words
although it was slower and we can
actually see the speed difference right
here this one took 5.8 seconds and this
one took just 1.1 seconds now in our
project we are prioritizing language
creationability over speed and cost so
we're going to stick with text DaVinci
003 but it's good to know for future
reference that you can do some
experimentation with this tool When
selecting a model to use although this
answer is short the language it provides
is actually perfect human standard
English so remember those older models
are not just there for legacy they are
actually really useful now the second
tool I want to show you is back on open
ai's website site and it is the open AI
playground and again this slide is a
clickable link now the playground is a
really really cool tool you can select
from some pre-written examples or you
can just come in here and write your own
prompts let's ask about Picasso again
and when we click submit we can actually
see the results we get highlighted in
green and this will allow you to
practice with different models again you
can change it right here but of course
you won't be seeing the results side by
side it also does allow you to play with
the various other settings some of which
we'll be looking at later in this course
but what I think is the most useful
thing here is that anytime you can come
up here to where it says view code and
get a code snippet including the prompt
you're generating right now it will
actually give you that prompt in either
node.js python or curl now I've selected
the node.js snippet right here if we
look carefully we can see that it's not
quite the same as the fetch request that
we've already written if we look at this
first line it's using the require
keyword to work with a dependency so at
the moment we couldn't just cut and
paste this code as it is but we could
use lots of it in our JS we've got for
example The Prompt right here but look
the neatness and compactness of the API
call being made here is definitely
making me think that it's time to move
away from the standard fetch request
we've already written and move towards
using the open AI dependency in the long
run this is going to save us time and
allow us to do less work in the next
Grim let's go back to the app and
refactor our fetch request to use the
openai dependency when you're ready for
that I'll see you there
so far we've been using a fetch request
to make API calls but now we're going to
neaten things up a bit by switching to
the open AI dependency and this is
actually going to save us time and allow
us to write less code as the project
progresses now if we look back at the
docs we saw this code snippet for
node.js and we can actually get a broad
idea from this as to what we want to
achieve let's just zoom in a little bit
okay so we're going to need to get our
hands on the configuration and open AI
API Constructors from the open AI
dependency and we'll actually be using
the import keyword not requiring them
because obviously we're not working in
node.js also like they're doing here we
are going to store our API key in a
separate file and we'll talk about that
more in a moment and then we'll use the
two Constructors that we're bringing in
from the openai dependency and then we
can update and simplify our fetch
request so firstly let's come over here
and I'm going to set up a new file file
called m.js now you can't actually see
me do this but when you hover your
cursor here three dots appear when you
click on them you get a menu and you can
select new file I'm going to call this
file
m.js and there we are we can see that
file has now appeared now remember
because we're working on the front end
this file is totally visible if you are
taking this to production this file
would need to be server side and of
course you would also make sure you were
ignoring it when pushing it to GitHub
but what we're doing today is purely on
the front end and this is absolutely
fine while we're developing and running
things locally and as I said towards the
end of the course we will look at how
you can deploy your projects with your
API key safely hidden and then you'll be
able to share your work and use it in
your portfolios okay so in this m file
I'm going to export a const
and this const will be process
and process is going to hold an object
and inside that object we're going to
have a key value pair where the key is
EnV
and the value will be an object with
another key value pair this time the key
will be open AI API key
and I've put that in uppercase letters
with underscores separating each word
now the value in that key value pair
will be our API key so let's just copy
and paste that from index.js
now we've done it like this with this
environment variable to more closely
mimic what we would be doing If This
Were a production app and this file were
being stored on the server and now that
we've got the API key in one place when
you come to doing the challenges and
we've got various API calls happening in
the app you'll only have to paste your
API key in one place right let's go back
to index.js and we're going to import
that environment variable so I'll come
right up to the top and I'll say import
and then in curly braces we need process
and then we need from and now we just
need the path to our environment
variable which is just going to be slash
NV and this should work because in
index.js if we scroll down to the bottom
we've already got this piece of code
right here type equals module so the
browser knows to expect modular
JavaScript now let's check it's working
so what I'm going to do is comment out
this API key and I'll set up a new const
called API key
and I'll have that store the API key
that we're importing with process so it
will be process
and then we're going to need dot MV and
then dot open AI API key
let's hit save and see if it works so
I'll come in here click the button
and there we are enthusiastic and
excited Okay so we've got our API key
where I want it next let's install the
open AI dependency and we'll come on to
that in the next scrim
okay let's install the open AI
dependency and in scrimber that's dead
easy over here on the left hand side
then I'll come to the three dot menu and
I've got the option to add dependency
and again that is not recorded but a
dialog box appears and I just need to
enter the dependency I want and in this
case that is just going to be open AI
all as one word and lowercase I hit add
and there we are the dependency has
appeared on the left hand side so
scrimber has done all of the hard work
for me in the background now if you're
working outside of the scrimber
environment perhaps you're following
this on YouTube or creating your own
project in vs code or any other editor
we will talk about how you can work with
the open AI dependency in just a couple
of scrims time now that we've got the
dependency installed we need to import
two Constructors from that dependency
let's just check this code so we're
going to need configuration and the open
AI API and they both have uppercase
first letters now they use require here
we are using import so let's just come
up here and say import
and we need configuration
and open AI API
and just note that AI here has got
uppercase letters that caught me out the
first time now we're importing them from
open AI
and let's just sort out my typos
and the first thing that we're going to
do is set up a new instance of this
configuration Constructor so down here
I'm going to say const
configuration with a lowercase C and
I'll set that equals to a new instance
of configuration
and as we can see here we'll need to
pass in our API key inside an object
and we've actually got the code we need
for that right here now we need to use
this second Constructor the open AI API
so I'll come down here and I'll set up a
const open AI
and this will store a new instance of
the open AI API
and we just need to pass in the new
instance of configuration that we just
created oh and I've just noticed that
I've made a mistake right here the AI is
uppercase but API is actually camel case
so we need to change that here
and here glad I saw that before we got a
strange error okay now we can delete a
load of code so we're not going to need
this URL anymore we're not going to need
the API key saved in here we actually
only used it here for a test so let's
delete all of that and now in the next
Grim we're going to come down here to
this fetchbot reply function and we're
going to make a lot of changes to all of
this code right here when you're ready
for that I'll see you there
so we're going to tidy up this function
a lot all we actually want to keep is
the model and the prompt so I'm just
going to delete everything else
now I am going to keep this line right
here where we update the speech bubble
but I'm just going to comment it out for
now and we'll need to make a few changes
to it in a moment now I'm going to come
in here and set up a const response
and now as per the code we've got in
here we can await our new instance of
the open AI API
so remember we've got that stored as a
const right here next we need to tell it
to use the create completion endpoint
and then just like they've done here
we're going to pass in an object with
our model and prompt so let's just cut
and paste that right in here
now let's log out the response
so I'm going to hit save
and it looks like we're getting an error
it says syntax error unexpected reserved
word so here's a quick debug challenge
for you can you figure out what's going
wrong here just pause now and take a
second to look at that
okay so hopefully you figured out that
because we're using the await keyword
right here we actually need this
function to be async
okay let's try that again and we're not
getting any errors so I'll press the
button and there we are we're getting
our response and if we look down in the
console we're getting the completion
excited passionate eager okay so to get
this rendered this line of code needs to
change just a little bit let's just
bring it up here and uncomment it so all
we need to do here is take this from
response
so it's response dot data dot choices
and then we'll take text from whatever
is at the zero index of the choices
array let's give it a go
and there we are it is working excited
enthusiastic driven now I'm just going
to delete this console.log and you might
well notice that we've got a lot of
white space up here and actually if I
just copy and paste something from the
console
you can see that the completion starts
with white space so here's a quick
JavaScript revision challenge for you
how do you remove the white space from
the beginning and the end of a string
just pause now and do that
okay so hopefully you remembered that we
can do that with the trim method so I'll
chain that on the end
let's hit save and I'll press the button
one last time
and there we are now it is at least
equally spaced out and as I said before
the CSS wasn't really designed to cope
with such a short completion but soon
the text that we generate is going to be
much longer okay we have seen various
enthusiastic responses from openai but
the next thing that I want to look at is
making that response actually tailored
to whatever the user puts inside this
text area so I want to get open AI
responding to our user's input in a
human manner but before we do that I did
promise that we'd quickly look at
running our code outside of the scrimber
environment so the next Grim is optional
if you're working on this in scrimber or
if you've already set this up locally
you can actually skip the next scrim and
move straight ahead when you're ready
let's move on
let's see how we can get this project up
and running in vs code with the open AI
dependency so the first thing to do is
to come on to this or any other scrim
and you don't need to have a scrimber
account to do this you can just click
this Cog icon down in the bottom right
hand corner that's going to bring up a
menu select download a zip you need to
unzip that package on your PC and then
open the folder in vs code so it's just
file and open folder and often the
folder has actually got this really
convoluted randomly generated name and
of course you can change that to
whatever you want now inside this folder
we've got several files this one here is
called read me for a reason let's open
it and see what it says and basically
it's telling us that we need to run npm
install and npm start so what we need to
do then is open up the terminal and when
we do that we will get a new instance of
the terminal down here and this is where
we can write npm install and I've just
put it a little bit bigger there just so
you can read it when you do that npm
install is going to do its thing once
it's done down here you can run npm
start and again there it is a little bit
bigger and that will do its thing and
eventually down in the terminal you will
see this and so to run the project
locally now all we need to do is go to
this link and the link is made of your
local IP address and this port so the
port in this case is 5173 now you could
replace your local IP address with
localhost and then have the colon and
then the port that will also work just
fine the quickest way to click on this
link is in Mac to hold down command in
Windows to hold down control and then
that link becomes clickable and it
should take you through to your browser
with the project running and you can see
here I'm accessing this on localhost but
the IP address would work for that just
fine
before we get to work on our response
from the AI I want to make a slight
change when we have just one word in
these Keys we don't need them to be
wrapped in inverted commas now it's a
totally personal thing but I prefer it
without where possible so let me just
tidy this up a little bit okay I feel
strangely better for doing that even
though it doesn't matter at all let's
get to work with personalizing the
response we get back from the AI so at
the moment we've given it this rather
basic prompt and you only get back as
much as you put in so it's giving us
this very boring generic reply and if we
hit send we'll see an example of that
excited and eager okay so thanks for
that but to be honest we could have
hard-coded it ourselves what I want to
do is uncomment this code here so what's
happening now is when a user clicks the
send button the if Clause here is going
to check that there is actually some
text in the text area if there is it's
going to render the low loading SVG and
update the speech bubble to our first
generic message at that point I also
want it to call fetchbot now if we're
going to get a personalized response
then our prompt needs to have access to
whatever the user entered into the text
area so let's take whatever that is and
save it as a const user input and we'll
pass in user input when we call fetch
bot reply and let's bring it into
fetchbot reply as the parameter outline
because it's going to be a one sentence
outline of a movie now the last change
I'm going to make here is I just want to
log out the response okay and now it's
time for a challenge for you and I'm
just going to come in here and I'm going
to paste it right inside this object
because it's this prompt here that I'm
going to ask you to refactor so I want
you to refactor this prompt so the AI
gives an enthusiastic personalized
response to the user's input and says it
needs a few moments to think about it
now a couple of things for you to think
about we can use the parameter outline
in the prompt by converting that prompt
to a template literal with backticks and
you might want to put the outline in
inverted commas or speech marks to
signal to open AI that this is a chunk
of text that you're referring to with
the rest of the prompt and of course you
can experiment with the wording but
don't be afraid to just ask for what you
want there's not one correct way of
writing this prompt and afterwards I'll
show you my way now just before you do
that I'm going to do you a favor I'm
actually going to break the rules again
and add a line of code here that we
haven't talked about yet now I want to
do that because I'm aware that we've
looked at loads of theory and we've laid
loads of Foundations but there hasn't
been too much time for you to get your
hands on the keyboard yet so I just want
to pop this line of code in here because
without it this challenge would be
ridiculously frustrating and then we
will talk about it afterwards so all I'm
going to do is add a property to this
object Max tokens 60. okay so pause now
don't worry about this mysterious new
property at all get this challenge
sorted and we'll have a look together in
just a minute
okay so hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so I'm going to come in here
and I'm going to completely replace this
prompt and what I'm going to say is this
generate a short message to
enthusiastically say outline sounds
interesting and that you need some
minutes to think about it mention one
aspect of the sentence so you'll have
noticed that I've put outline in
inverted commas so the AI understands
that I want it to deal with that
specific line of text and also this last
instruction will hopefully make open AI
personalize the completion now of course
to get access to outline we need to swap
these four backticks
okay let's hit save and I'm just going
to put a one-line idea in here
and I'm just going to say a spy deep
Behind Enemy Lines falls in love with an
enemy agent let's press send
and look at that we're getting a really
long completion and if you just read
through that you can see that it's
actually like we're interacting with a
human it's being conversational it's
referring to our idea and that is
exactly what we want now down in the
console we've got the response and just
bear with me while I copy and paste
something from there
now before I explain why I've done that
I'm just going to actually use the same
idea again but this time I'm going to
remove this line of code that I added
just before you did the challenge
so I said a spy beat Behind Enemy Lines
falls in love with an enemy agent let's
press send and see what happens and
there we are we get our response but
look it is much shorter a spy deep
Behind Enemy Lines falls in love with
Anne and then it stops my answer is cut
off now I'm just going to copy and paste
the same properties from the response
and what we can see there is that the
first time with the more successful
completion we had the finished reason of
stop and the second time when the
completion was actually not complete
where we got cut off the finished reason
was length so generally speaking a
finished reason of length is bad news it
means open AI has not given us
everything it wanted to now also at the
end here we see completion tokens 59 in
the first call and completion tokens 16
in the second call so something we're
doing with tokens is affecting the
length of the completion we get now as
you're a seasoned coder you've probably
grasped that we can control the length
of our completion to some extent with
this Max tokens property but before we
start using Max tokens all over the
place we should really understand what a
token is in open Ai and what this number
60 really means so in the next Grim
let's take a peek under the hood and
take a dive into tokens and the max
tokens property when you're ready for
that move on
okay let's talk about tokens and the max
tokens property so we know that when we
add this Max tokens of 60 to our API
request we get plenty of text back we
also know that if we don't set max
tokens we get much less text back and
it's actually not complete and therefore
doesn't really make sense and that's
what we can actually see right here so
what exactly is going on with tokens and
what even are tokens open AI breaks down
chunks of text for processing now I say
text it depends on which model you're
using and what you're doing it could
also be code that gets broken down into
chunks but we're working with text so we
need to think about tokens in the
context of text now you might think that
each word or each syllable would be a
token but it's actually not as simple as
that roughly speaking a token is about
75 percent of word so a hundred tokens
is about 75 words so the 60 token limit
that we put on this fetch request would
bring us back a maximum of about 40
words when we didn't use max tokens at
all this one here actually defaulted to
16 which as we can see here is way too
short for our needs so that's an
important lesson if you don't allow
enough tokens your completion will be
cut short so you'll actually get less
text back from open AI so now you might
be thinking well okay a token is a chunk
of text but so what why do I need to
think about limiting it and the best way
to make sure that your max token setting
isn't causing you problems is to check
the object you get with your response if
you see the finished reason of length
that is a bad sign that means the text
that you're getting back has been cut
short and if you see a finished reason
of stop that is a good sign that means
the open a AI actually got to the end of
the process and it's given you all of
the text that it wanted to give you so
you might be thinking okay so a token is
a chunk of text but why does that matter
well there are some good reasons for
knowing about tokens and being able to
limit them each token incurs a charge
and it takes time to process so that
gives you an incentive if you limit the
number of tokens you can keep costs down
and keep performance up and that's
really important of course for when you
run out of free credit and if you're
creating a production app and that app
scales to millions and millions of users
and why shouldn't it now there's
something really important about Max
tokens that we need to understand Max
tokens does not help us control how
concise a text is as we saw in our app
we get an incomplete response when the
token count is low not a more concise
one so as a tool to control how verbose
or how expressive open AI is Mac tokens
is useless and that begs the question
how should I use it and the answer is we
should set it high enough to allow a
full response from open AI so you might
just have to do a little bit of
experimentation with that each time and
just making sure the text that you get
back from the API is not cut short
so how can we control the length of text
we get from open AI well we do that with
prompt design good prompt design is
everything and good prompt design is the
best way to ensure that the text we get
from open AI is the length we want now I
actually think that the text that we got
back when we had Max token set to 60 was
just a little bit too long so as we go
through this project and we learn more
about prompt design we will come back
and just do a little bit of refactoring
here but for now I want to keep up the
momentum keep moving forwards so let's
start tackling our next API call which
is to generate a full synopsis from our
one sentence movie idea when you're
ready for that let's move on
Okay so we've got the one sentence idea
from the user now let's make it into a
professional synopsis for our movie so
I'm going to come down here and set up a
function called Fetch synopsis
and of course this will be an async
function now eventually when the app's
finished we'll be displaying the
synopsis to our user in this container
which will pop up when the finished
movie Pitch is ready to display and the
synopsis will actually be right down
here at the bottom now if we have a look
over in the HTML this is the section
here which is actually going to contain
all of the output and it's this
paragraph down here output text which
will contain the synopsis so at the
moment this whole container is hidden by
default but if we go over to index.css
and we just uncomment that one line
there now that container has appeared at
the bottom so in this new function that
I've set up fetch synopsis what I'm
going to do is take control of this
paragraph that we've got right here with
the ID of output text and then we'll be
able to display our synopsis right there
just to check it's working so inside the
fetch function we want to say document
dot get element by ID
and the ID is output Dash text
and we'll set the inner text
to whatever text we get back from the
API and we can just borrow that line of
code right there because in every case
the text that we get back from open AI
comes in an object and it is always
actually in the same place now I'm going
to call fetch synopsis from right here
inside this event listener and I'll put
it right underneath where we get the
first reply to our initial idea
and I'll pass in the user input because
that will also be needed to get the
synopsis
and of course let's take that in as a
parameter right here and again I'll just
call it outline
okay now it's time for a big challenge
for you and I'm just going to paste it
right in here
so I want you to set up an API call with
model prompt and Max tokens properties
The Prompt should ask for a synopsis for
a movie based on the outline supplied by
the user which of course we're bringing
in with this parameter outline and just
remember when writing prompts try to be
specific descriptive and as detailed as
possible about the desired outcome try
to avoid fluffy and imprecise
descriptions so don't use phrases like
sort of or roughly now we said before
that we can control the length of the
output with good prompt design now you
could experiment here with asking for a
particular word count say give me a
synopsis of 150 words but I just want to
warn you that that's likely to be quite
imprecise so don't be frustrated if the
length of the text you get is not what
you want we will be dealing with that
shortly okay there is quite a lot to do
here but you've got all of the skills
you need to do this so pause now and get
it sort it
okay so hopefully you managed to get a
really good synopsis let's have a look
together inside here I am going to set
up a const called response
and then we'll await and open AI create
completion
and we need to pass that an object with
our model prompt and Max tokens so the
model is text DaVinci 003
I'll put my prompt in backticks so we
can use the outline and I'm just going
to say generate an engaging professional
and marketable movie synopsis based on
the following idea
and lastly we need Max tokens because
remember Max tokens will actually
default to 16 and we don't really need
that comment there anymore so I will say
Max tokens
and I'm going to go for something pretty
big because I don't want our text to get
cut off so I'll say 700 and we can
always reduce that later
okay let's hit save and give it a try so
for my idea I'm going with this
a Madman develops a machine to control
all humans
and only intelligent animals can save
the human race
although would they really want to
anyway let's give that a try and see
what we get
so we're going to get our first message
from the API again we've got this pretty
long response and we're waiting now for
the synopsis and I'm just going to
scroll down because it's just going to
appear right here inside this box okay
and there we are we get our synopsis and
the results we get back are fine now I'm
just going to copy and paste them
because actually you'll probably find
that if you pause you won't be able to
scroll the mini browser so let me just
paste them right here inside this file
now the first thing that we can say is
that that is pretty impressive we've got
a long body of text very much as if it
was written by a human so pretty happy
with that and although it's long it does
finish naturally I don't think it's
actually been cut short by having too
few tokens I think 700 is plenty but I
do wonder if it's as good as it could be
now our prompt instruction that I've
written here is fairly good but it's
actually quite hard to describe what
exactly you want a longer passage of
text to be like in detail and as we've
talked about several times it's also
quite hard to control the length this is
arguably quite long now I've just
counted the words here and it comes in
at just over 160 that's actually not bad
but we can't really rely on that also I
can't help feeling that these story it's
laid out is just a little bit woolly it
would be nice if it was just a little
bit tighter a little bit more concise if
we're going to grab the movie Studio's
attention we need it to be really sharp
so what I want to look at next is how we
can help open AI understand more about
what we want
so far we've been giving open AI these
simple one-line instructions what I want
to try next is to include one or more
examples actually inside the prompt to
give open AI a push in the right
direction so it's going to give us more
of what we want so let's take a look at
that next
so far when writing prompts we've just
provided one or more sentences asking
for what we want you'll often hear this
referred to as the zero shot approach
and what that means is it's just an
instruction now the zero shot approach
works really well for many simple
requests but when we work with more
complex requests we run a greater risk
of getting back results that don't
really fulfill our needs so we might get
completions which are off topic or too
long or perhaps the format is just not
what we want now I've got an example of
that happening right here let me
introduce you to advertify which is an
app I've made to generate copy for
advertising purposes it's pretty simple
the user can input a product name give a
description and a target market they hit
generate copy and they get a bunch of
text they can use in their adverts and
if we just have a quick look at the code
there's nothing unfamiliar going on here
we're bringing in the user inputs right
here from the inputs and this text area
and then down here we've got this one
line prompt and it's a basic instruction
and it's just using the product name
product description and the product
Target so the instruction is just create
50 words of advertising copy for this
product which can be described as the
product description and aimed at the
product target market and we might just
tidy up that last backtick and bring it
all onto one line let's see this in
action but before we do that I'm just
going to log out the response now I'm
going to go for the same vegan fish
cream example that we've got in the
paceholder text
and I'll hit generate copy and let's see
what we get
and okay it's working but look it's
given me an ordered list we've got one
two three four five and six and it looks
a little bit longer than 50 words but if
we open up the console we can actually
see that we've got this and I'll just
paste it in here it says finish reason
of length and as I'm sure you'll recall
that means that open AI has actually cut
a short and if you look number six is
not complete it just says grab your
vegan Dash and at that point we know
that open AI was trying to give us more
now I've tried this several times before
recording with various prompts and open
AI really doesn't work that well with
word counts the five words or less that
we used in a previous challenge does
seem to work okay but longer word counts
often fail now interestingly open AI
does know how long a tweet is if we were
to change this prompt and ask for a
tweet it will nearly always deliver
something that's tweet length and throw
in some hashtags as well okay let's try
something else and see if we can make
this advertify app work a little bit
better we're going to have a look at the
fuse shot approach the fuchsia approach
is where we add one or more examples to
our prompt we do this because it helps
the AI and understand what we want this
is great for more complex tasks so let's
refactor our prompt firstly I'm going to
remove all of the variables and actually
rewrite this instruction so I've said
use a product name a product description
and a target market to create
advertising copy for a product at the
moment we're not doing anything with the
user input so that's just going to give
us something really really random but
what we're going to do next is layout an
example so staying inside the backticks
I'll come down onto a new line and
here's my example
so I've got a product name which is
flask Thai a product description a tie
with a pouch to hold liquids and a straw
to drink through and the product target
market is office workers now I've also
put some advertising copy right here and
that advertising copy is about 54 words
long which is the kind of length I'm
looking for now before this is going to
work we need to do a couple of things
firstly we need to bring back our
variables and we're going to lay them
out in the same style as our example so
in fact I'm just going to copy and paste
all of that text and now let's bring in
the user inputs so flask tie we can
replace with product name product
description we can replace with product
desk and of course target market will be
product Target
now advertising copy we are just going
to leave that empty so can you see what
we've done here we've given an example
and then we've given a partly completed
example and this space right here is an
invitation for open AI to go and
complete and if you'll remember we're
using the create completion endpoint so
open AI is just going to complete this
block of text here in the same style as
this block of text here it's going to
recognize that we want it to give us
something like that but tailored to the
three variables that we've got right
here if we tested this right now it
would likely work but there's one more
thing that we can do to help the AI and
to make our code more readable what
we're going to do is separate our our
instructions and context now open AI
docs suggest that you can do this with
three inverted commas or three hash
symbols I'm just going to go for the
hash symbols and I'm going to put one
set right here after the instruction and
then I'll put another set down here in
between my example and where we're
asking open AI to do its thing and so
all that's doing is breaking up this
body of text a little bit so open AI can
see that it's dealing with different
entities an instruction an example and a
request to go and complete okay let's
hit save and see if it works so I'm
going to put in the same vegan fish
cream
and I'll hit generate copy okay let's
check out the copy we've got so firstly
we haven't got this ordered list there's
no numbers one to six what we've got is
a body of advertising text and that is
what I wanted
secondly I've just checked the word
count of this and it's actually coming
in as 63 words now the example that I
put here is actually 54 words so there's
only nine words between the two and that
is pretty good and if we have a look
down in the console we can see that the
finished reason is stop that makes sense
because this is very much the end of the
sentence and the end of the text so open
AI has given us everything that it
wanted to give us so the example is
doing a really good job of allowing us
to show open AI what it is we want now
remember this is called the few shot and
we can add one or more examples we
should remember however that longer
prompts cost more so you don't want to
go too far but let's go ahead and add
one more example and actually this is
something that you're going to do as a
challenge so let's get straight on to
that in the next scrim
okay so here's your challenge add a
second example here be sure to make it
similar in design to the first now I've
put that because we don't want to
confuse the AI the examples that we give
should be in a similar format and they
should be consistent else we're just
creating confusion now I've also put
here remember to use separators so that
is these three triple hashtags and you
can use them in exactly the same way to
separate out your example from the
request to create now one thing I want
you to remember here is that the law of
diminishing returns applies adding more
and more examples will not guarantee
better results you might see great
results or you might not also before you
do this challenge I just want to say
that I'm aware that some people flowing
this course might be at a disadvantage
here because English is not their first
language or perhaps language is just
something they struggle with so I've
added a file up here called product.md
and that has got an example that you can
use so you can copy the text and just
stick to practicing the layout and the
syntax of the prompt okay pause now get
this challenge sorted and I'll see you
back here in just a minute
okay hopefully you got that working so
I'm just going to come in here and I'm
going to copy all of the text that I've
got right here and let's just put our
second example underneath the first
first thing that I want to do is
separate out the examples so we'll
borrow these hashtags now I'm just going
to take the product name and that will
be solar swim product description it's
this crazy swimming costume with solar
cells to charge your phone while you're
on the beach or what have you and we've
got the target market which is of course
young adults who'll spend their money on
anything finally we've got the
advertising copy and that is
approximately the same length and style
as the advertising copy we've got right
here so that should do the trick let's
just remove that space and we'll hit
save and let's give it a go and I'll hit
generate copy and okay again that has
been pretty successful the word count is
coming in at just under 50 words well
our examples were 54 words and 53 words
respectively so that is pretty good and
also I think we're getting pretty decent
copy be now it can be really really hard
to judge because openai is not going to
give you the same completion for the
same prompt each time so it's really
hard to judge when you refactor a prompt
exactly how much difference is made but
I think two examples is a pretty good
amount for this view shot approach and
it's definitely had a beneficial effect
on this app so what we need to do now is
go back to the function that generates
our synopsis and see if the fuse shot
approach will improve it when you're
ready for that let's move on
okay so we have this synopsis fetch
request and perhaps we can tighten up
the synopsis we get back and improve it
by adding an example or two with a few
shot approach now when you do this
you're welcome to use your own examples
in fact I would encourage you to do that
if you're going to be working with open
AI then it's important to practice
creating prompts however I have put an
example synopsis up here in synopsis.md
which you can use if you'd like to when
you complete this challenge so your
challenge is to refactor this prompt to
use one or more examples just like we
did in the previous scrim and remember
to separate out the instruction from the
example with either the triple hash or
the triple inverted comma check back if
you need to remind yourself of the
syntax and I'll see you back here in
just a moment
okay hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so I'm going to come in here
and we're going to rework this prompt
and I'm going to replace this with the
following
generate an engaging professional and
marketable movie synopsis based on an
outline now I'll come down onto a new
line I'm going to add my hashtag
separator and then I'll add my example
and my example needs an outline and a
synopsis
and I'm going to use the examples I
prepared earlier this is the outline
and then we'll also take the synopsis
and I've made sure that this example
synopsis is the kind of thing that I
want to get back from open AI
now underneath that we'll add another
separator
and then it's outline
and this is where we need to bring in
the user generated outline
and then the synopsis
which of course we can leave blank okay
let's hit save and I'm just going to pop
over to the CSS and I'll just uncomment
this one one more time so we'll see the
synopsis appear here and let's put in a
one sentence idea
so I've gone for a Madman develops a
machine to control all humans and only
intelligent animals can save the human
race there we're getting our long
initial response and then down here
let's just wait for the synopsis
and there it is okay the first thing I
want to do is check the word count
and the good news is it's almost exactly
the same length as this example there's
less than 10 words in it now also and
this is subjective but if you read
through it I think this is a pretty good
synopsis to me it seems tight it tells
the whole story it packs a lot of detail
in there's not too much fluff so I'm
pretty happy with that and again as
always with open AI it's really hard to
make a comparison but I think adding
that example to The Prompt has made a
big difference now of course the
synopsis makes this prompt quite big and
if we were to add several examples we
could end up burning tokens here
unnecessarily so if we were going to
take this to production maybe we would
run a bunch of tests with multiple
synopses and then reduce the number to
the minimum needed now before we move on
I have got one more challenge for you
and I'm just going to come up here and
paste it in okay so the initial response
that we get back when we first put our
one line concept into the text area is
pretty long it doesn't actually break
the layout but it does just stretch
things a bit too much and I think it's
all a bit unnecessary what I'd prefer is
to see something like this so we've got
a good personalized response but it's
just not that long there's just enough
there to make it clear that open AI has
understood our request and is giving us
a conversational response which
references the one line input from the
user so here's a challenge for you I
want you to refactor this prompt to use
examples of an outline and an
enthusiastic response be sure to keep
the length of your examples reasonably
short say 20 words or so so we just
don't want it to be massive like this
one now again it's great if you can work
on this on your own but I have put a
file up here called outline line.md and
that has got some examples in it that
you can use but do write your own if
you're able okay pause now get this
challenge sorted and I'll see you back
here in just a minute
okay hopefully you got that working just
fine so I'm going to come in here and
I'm just going to change up this initial
instruction
I'm saying generate a short message to
enthusiastically say an outline sounds
interesting and that you need some
minutes to think about it now I'm not
going to instruct it to mention
something from the outline like we did
before mention one aspect of the
sentence what I want to do instead is
show it how to do that with examples so
let's come in here and put these
separator
and now I'm going to go over to
outline.md and I'm going to bring in the
examples that I've got right here
so I've got three examples and each one
has got an outline and a message so
let's just label them clearly
and I'm going to separate each example
with a separator
okay now let's come down onto a new line
we'll add another separator and then
we'll say outline and message and of
course message will leave blank because
that is what openai is going to do for
us and outline will just be the outline
that we've got coming in here as a
parameter
okay let's hit save and I'm going to use
the same example as I used before and
let's see what we get but before we do
that let's actually just get rid of the
output box that was at the bottom and
also just momentarily I'm going to
comment out this fetch synopsis function
so the app will only go so far as to
call this function I'll need to add my
outline again and let's hit go
okay there we're getting a much shorter
response wow that's incredible a madman
and his machine I'm feeling inspired
already let me take a few moments to
ponder it so a much shorter completion
just like our examples but still clearly
referring to the outline I put in okay
now the app is working much more
smoothly but before we move on there's
just one little thing I want to tidy up
we've got a global variable up here and
actually we're only using it right here
so my bad for declaring it globally I'm
just going to move it down here inside
that function and I think that is better
practice and a little bit neater now
next up in our app we need to create an
iconic title for our movie but I think
this would be a good moment for me to
say a quick word about the architecture
of this app so let's just take literally
a couple of minutes to talk about that
I just wanted to say a word about the
architecture of this app as always with
code there are loads of ways you could
do this so I want to say right now that
the way I'm doing it here is definitely
not the one best way and in an app this
size actually it's not going to matter
very much at all but there are some
things which we could do here which
we're not doing and I wanted to give you
an explanation as to why so firstly on
the code reusability front we are
building objects for each of our calls
to the API and as you can see before
this app is finished we will have done
that multiple times now would there be a
way to set up one function to do the
fetching and pass it an object with the
prompt Max tokens Etc every time we need
it probably yes and that would make our
code much more reusable and less
repetitive but the reason I'm not doing
that is just to let the AI take center
stage and not get bogged down in
JavaScript once you've got the basics of
working with openai as you will by the
end of this project that is the time to
start looking at ways of Saving Time
saving work and being more concise with
the code and likewise normally I like to
have my functions as much as possible
just doing one thing and we're breaking
that rule here because we've got a
function that's doing the fetching and
it's also rendering out to the Dom now
we could potentially set up one render
function and then have these fetch
functions just return the response and
then when all of the API calls have
completed the render function could
render out the results it would be
doable we could store all of our
completions in an object and have a
function that checks if all of the fetch
requests have responded successfully
before triggering the render but again
that would involve a whole lot more
JavaScript when in this course I really
want to just focus on the AI now at the
end of the course if you would like to
refactor the code that is not a bad idea
at all in fact it's a really good idea
but I just wanted to give you a quick
explanation now of why I chose to do it
like this okay with that done let's go
ahead and use openai to generate a movie
title that's so iconic it's going to
reverberate down through Cinema history
for the next 500 years when you're ready
for that let's move on
we need a title for our movie so let's
go ahead and set up a function to do
that now I'm going to call this function
fetch title and as you know by now that
is going to be an async function now if
we have a quick look over at index.html
we've got an element here it's actually
an H1 and that is where the title of our
movie is going to be rendered so back
inside this function then let's just
deal with that first
now we're going to generate this title
from a synopsis so we need to take that
in as a parameter I want to call this
function from inside this fetch synopsis
functions so as soon as this response
comes back with a synopsis we want to
send that synopsis straight back to open
AI to get us a title so I'll call the
function right here now we need to pass
in the synopsis and we've got that right
here but instead of writing out this
code several times why don't we actually
set that up as a const chord synopsis
and now we can use synopsis here and
we'll also pass it in to the fetch title
function okay you should be pretty good
at this by now so I'm going to leave the
rest of this function up to you just
bear with me while I paste in your
challenge
so I want you to write a prompt asking
for a title based on a synopsis if you'd
like to you can specify that the title
should be gripping or alluring and I say
that just to remind you that being
descriptive in prompt writing is a good
thing secondly remember that we need to
add the model property and of course we
should give it some Max tokens the
default Max tokens of 16 might be enough
that really depends on how long you
think a movie title should be I mean
some movie titles are really really
short the Stephen King Classic is for
example some are kind of medium to long
Pirates of the Caribbean the Curse of
the Black Pearl and then some are quite
ridiculous night of the day of the dawn
of the son of the Bride of the return of
the Revenge of the terror of the attack
of the evil mutant alien flesh eating
Hellbound zombified Living Dead part two
and that film is Real by the way but it
is a spoof film okay I'll leave that up
to you set some Max tokens that you
think are going to cover the kind of
title length that you want for your film
when I do this I'm probably going to set
it to something like 10. okay pause now
and go ahead and do this
okay so hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so I will come in here and set
up my response and then we will await
the create completion call and then
inside the object we need the model we
need the prompt and my prompt is just
going to be generate a catchy movie
title for this synopsis
and as for Max tokens I'm actually going
to go for 15 just to give myself plenty
of leeway if it does end up generating a
really long title okay let's hit save
and then down here we've still got this
display div visible remember in
index.css we've just commented out the
display None So eventually it will be
hidden and then we'll just show it at
the end when all of the API calls have
been completed and the finished product
is ready to show but for now let's just
watch when our synopsis and title appear
so I'm going to put in my one sentence
movie idea and this is quite a long one
a time traveler goes back to the 1980s
to prevent a catastrophic event but
falls in love with someone from the past
and must choose between saving the world
or staying with them let's hit send
there we've got our first bit of
feedback here comes the synopsis and
here is our title
1985 forever James Mason's time
traveling love story now I'm a little
bit concerned here that we've got a
quotation mark at the beginning but not
at the end and if we just count up how
many words we've got here and we bear in
mind that these are quite long words I'm
just a little bit worried that my Max
tokens of 15 might not be enough so I'm
actually just going to ER on the side of
caution and whack that up to about 25.
let's try that again and see what
happens
okay interesting this time it's actually
given us a much shorter title so we
don't actually know if the max tokens
would have made a difference or not in
that first attempt I should have logged
out the response then I would have been
able to actually see the reason for
finish was it stop or was it length but
never mind we've got a title and it's a
good title or is it that is rather a
matter of taste and to some extent a
matter of culture consider this in the
English-speaking world this spooky Bruce
Willis film is called The Sixth Sense
and millions and millions of people have
seen it in China it's actually called
he's a ghost which is just a much more
direct name and without wanting to give
away spoilers it's actually a title that
gives away key points of the plot so
ideas for titles will vary now we know
that we can adjust the kind of outcomes
we get from open AI with how we phrase
our prompts and we also know that we can
give examples and that will also tweak
the kind of responses we get but now I
want to introduce a new property which
is called temperature and we're just
going to add that property right here to
the object that we pass to open AI
before we dive in and start using
temperature let's just have a quick bit
of theory about what it does
so we know that openai works by
predicting the likelihood of one
language chunk or token following
another so if we had a phrase like the
dog well open AI could complete that as
the dog was sleeping the dog was hungry
the dog bit me there are millions and
millions of possibilities what
temperature does is it controls how
often the model outputs a less likely
token so what it's doing is giving us
some control over whether our
completions are safe and predictable on
the one hand or more creative and varied
on the other hand
now temperature is set from zero to one
in increments of 0.01 although you are
going to find it really hard to see the
difference with small changes now it
defaults to one so all of the API
requests we've made so far in our app
have used the default temperature of one
now lower temperatures for example at
zero we'll use fewer less likely tokens
so the completions will be less creative
and more predictable and this is
absolutely great if you're looking for
factual responses now higher
temperatures will use more less likely
tokens so in doing that you're going to
get more variety and more creativity now
I'm wondering if my titles are a bit too
wacky so I'm going to come in here and
I'll actually set the temperature to 0.7
and let's save that and give it a try so
I'm using the same outline as before and
here we are we've got a title back the
power of love Billy Biggs time travel
Adventure okay that is a pretty good
title now I have to reiterate it's very
very hard to compare completions because
there's so much variety anyway I could
experiment more I could take this down
to zero but to be honest I'm actually
happy with what I've got right here so
I'm going to leave temperature alone but
why don't you have a play around with it
and see how you like the results see if
you get a big difference or just a small
difference and remember how we're
generating our title we're actually
using the synopsis and the synopsis was
generated with a temperature setting of
one by default so if you lower the
temperature here in Fetch title and
you're still getting something which is
too weird for you try actually changing
the temperature property in this
function right here so there's no right
or wrong way to do this it's just a
matter of taste and of course it's
important to know about the temperature
property and how it works now we've come
a long way there's only two more things
that we need to do with this app we need
to get the cast and we need to generate
an image so when you're ready for that
let's move on
in our finished product we're going to
have a star-studded cast so movie
industry insiders can better visualize
our story and this is going to give us a
great chance to look at text extraction
using open AI if we have a look at our
fetch synopsis prompt in this example we
have actually got the actors names in
Brackets after each character but we're
not always seeing that in the output in
this screenshot we are we've got Jeff
Bridges and Emily Blunt but in this
screenshot we're actually not getting
that at all we've got the characters but
no names for suggested actors now that's
probably being a bit inconsistent
because we're not specifically asking
for it although we've got it in the
example we haven't got it in the
instruction so here's a very quick mini
challenge for you ask for actors names
in Brackets after each character and
I've just put here you could also
suggest that open AI thinks of actors
that would particularly suit the role
okay pause now and quickly sort out that
challenge
okay hopefully you got that to work just
fine I'm just going to add a sentence
onto the end of the instruction the
synopsis should include actors names in
Brackets after each character choose
actors that would be ideal for the role
okay let's save that and see if it's
worked so I'll put an idea in here and
we'll press send and there we are we've
got our synopsis and we can indeed see
that we're getting the actors names in
Brackets after each character now I've
tested this and it is very consistent
okay the next thing that we need then is
a function so we can extract the stars
names from this text so they can be
listed out right here just above our
synopsis you could do that with vanilla
JavaScript but it's actually going to be
easier to let open AI do that for us so
I'm going to come down here then and
after we've generated these synopsis at
the same time as we ask for the title
I'm going to call an another function
called Fetch Stars and of course we'll
pass in the synopsis now I'll come down
here and because you've done this lots
and lots of times I'm going to do all of
the heavy lifting here and set up that
function minus the prompt now we should
set some Max tokens here I think we
don't need very many but 30 will be more
than enough
and I'm not actually going to set a
temperature here I've tested this and it
really doesn't make much difference at
all so we might as well leave it at its
default now we can see on the screenshot
that we want the Stars right here let's
just check the HTML and we've got this
H2 element with the ID of output Dash
Stars so that is where we're going to
render Our Stars and of course this
function needs a parameter okay now it's
time for a challenge and I'm going to
paste it in right here just above the
prompt
I want you to use openai to extract the
names in Brackets from our synopsis now
I've left that challenge wide open
because I think we've done enough prompt
engineering by now for you to be able to
figure out how to do this if you feel
ready for that pause now go ahead get it
sorted it's always best to try and
figure things out on your own as much as
possible but if you'd like a few more
pointers or if you've tried it and
you've got stuck I have put a hint file
up here it's called hint.md and it's
just got a couple of pointers that will
push you in the right direction okay
pause now get this challenge sorted do
some experimentation take all the time
you need and I'll see you back here when
you've got it working and we'll have a
look together
okay hopefully you got that working just
fine so I'm going to come in here and
I'm going to start off with a simple
instruction extract the names in
Brackets from the synopsis
that should do the trick because open AI
is more than capable of recognizing
names and brackets but what I do want to
do though is add an example so I'm going
to come down here onto a new line and
I'll use a divider so that will be the
triple hashtag and now I'm actually
going to take the example that we've got
up here it's this Top Gun one so we can
borrow all of that
and I'll just paste it in here now we've
got all of the names in Brackets so
let's just show open AI what it is we're
looking for so I'll say names and then a
colon and then I'll just list out all of
the names from the brackets
so Tom Cruise Val Kilmer and Kelly
McGillis and if we have a look back at
the slide we're actually getting a comma
separated list here and that is actually
what we want so those commas are there
for a reason now let's come on to a new
line again and I'll use a divider and
now let's just put synopsis colon and
this is where we want to pass it the
synopsis that we're bringing in right
here and then underneath that names
and we'll leave that blank because that
is where open AI is going to do its
thing okay let's hit save and we'll see
if it's working I'll paste an idea in
and hit send
and let's check out our results so we've
got a title and there we are we have got
our Stars Al Pacino Kevin Hart and
Dwayne Johnson what a lineup that I
think will just be a really really cool
film and we've also got a decent
synopsis now the final thing that we
need to finish this app off is an image
but before we can do that we need to
learn about generating images with open
AI That's a little bit different to
everything we've done so far so let's
investigate that next
okay let's take a look at generating
images with open AI so you've probably
seen open ai's image generation tool
darli and if you haven't you really
should take a moment to go and play with
it this link is of course clickable it
will take you straight there it really
really is a lot of fun now as well as
the Dali playground we can access the
open AI image API which allows us to
generate images in our application and
I'm actually building one such
application right here it's a really
simple fun game all you have to do is
describe a famous painting without
saying the name of the painting or the
name of the artist so if I wanted to
generate an image of the most famous
painting in the world I could say
something like a 16th century woman with
long brown hair standing in front of a
green Vista with Cloudy Skies she's
looking at the viewer with a faint smile
on her lips and if I give that
description to open AI hopefully it's
going to give me a good likeness of the
moment Elisa which is going to appear
right here inside this picture frame now
all of these CSS and HTML for this app
is already done we just need to finish
off the JavaScript and there's nothing
unfamiliar Happening Here the user is
going to input their image description
right here click create there's an event
listener on that button and it is going
to call generate image generate image is
going to call the open AI image API so
let's go ahead and set up a response
right here and up until now this is
where we've been using the create
completion endpoint and now we want to
use the create image endpoint now just
like with create completion we need to
pass an object with a set of properties
but actually these are not the same
properties as we've used before with
create completion we actually don't need
to specify a model we don't need to give
it Max tokens or temperature let's just
have a quick look at the properties that
we do need so first up we need a prompt
this will be a description of the image
and we'll go into more detail about
prompt writing for images in just a
moment the second property is n and n
just stands for number and it controls
the number of images we get back from
openai now we can pass it an integer
between 1 and 10. so the maximum number
of images we can get in one go is 10 and
it will actually default to one so
strictly speaking I didn't need to add
it here but it's really really important
that you know it's there because in the
future you might want to to work with
multiple images next up we've got size
and size takes in a string and that
string is going to hold the size in
pixels of the image we want we've
actually got three choices here we can
have two five six by two five six five
twelve by 512 or 10 24 by 1024 Now the
default here is the big one 1024 by 1024
and remember bigger images cost more
credit so what you don't want to do is
just always leave that at the default
take the biggest images and then resize
it to something much smaller with CSS
that's really uneconomical so just be
careful to go for the image size that
you want today we'll be going for these
smaller image and the last property
we've got here is the response format
and that is also a string and the string
can either be URL or b64 underscore Json
so what this is giving us is the format
of the completion if it gives us a URL
we can just use that UR URL as a source
inside an image element and actually
this will default to URL and when you're
doing the challenges I recommend that
you use URL but there's a bit more we
need to say about response format
firstly you need to be aware that open
AI image URLs only last for one hour so
if you want to keep an image you need to
download it as I'm recording this and my
images need to last longer than an hour
I'm actually going to use this b64
underscore Json method and this is going
to give me an encoded PNG image so I
don't need to rely on open ai's URLs now
if you've never worked with a base64
encoded image before all it is is a
massive chunk of code which the browser
can interpret as an image this is one
that I've just pasted into vs code and
it is absolutely huge if you try and log
this out in scrimber you'll likely
actually crash the editor you can search
online for base64 image to PNG
conversions and you'll find plenty of
sites where you can just paste in all of
this code and it will just give you an
image but what's also important to know
is that you can add a little bit of code
just before the source in the image tag
to tell the browser to expect a base64
encoded image and we're going to see
that in just a moment a quick word about
prompt design prompt writing for images
is actually less complex than the prompt
writing we've done for text so far all
we really need to do is describe what we
want in detail in a maximum of 1000
characters now the more detailed the
description the more likely you are to
get back the results that you want so
consider this if you ask for a white dog
that's a bad description you're not
giving any detail at all and you're
exerting no control over what you're
going to get back if on the other hand
you ask for a close-up Studio
photographic portrait of an Old English
Sheepdog well that is a good description
and then you can really start to imagine
what you're going to get back and you'll
actually find with that level of detail
it's quite easy to exert control over
the images you get back from openai
let's get the rest of this coded out and
then we can actually see it all in
action so I'm going to come in here and
the first thing that we need is a prompt
and that prompt is going to be whatever
we've brought in here as a parameter
which is whatever the user has inputted
into the box here next we need n and we
only want one image today so I could
leave out n it does default to one but
as I said I just want to keep reminding
you that it is there for when you need
it next we need size and that one is a
string and I'm going for the smallest
option which is 256 by 256 and that is
just a lowercase x right there in the
middle now lastly we want the response
format
and again this is a string and I'm just
going to set it to URL now that is the
code that it's best for you to use when
doing these challenges you're going to
get back a URL and I've already set up
this image element right here the source
is using the URL and therefore the image
is going to appear right here as I said
before I can't do that I actually need
to use base64 Json so that's b64
underscore Json and that does mean that
I won't be taking the URL because
actually this is not going to give us a
URL it's actually going to give us this
base64 encoded image so I'm going to
change URL to b64 underscore Json now I
would log that out to show you so you
could see the full response but actually
the base64 encoder Json is so big as I
think I said before it actually crashed
the browser so I won't do that but feel
free to experiment now there's one last
thing that I need to do to make this
work you're not going to need to do it
if you're using the URL format but I'm
just going to paste a little bit of code
right in here
and what this code does is it just tells
the browser that what's coming up is
actually a data version of an image it's
a PNG image and the data type is base64.
without that code right there this will
not work so let's save it
and see if we can describe the most
famous picture of all time
so I'm putting in here a 16th century
woman with long brown hair standing in
front of a green Vista with Cloudy Skies
she's looking at the viewer with a faint
smile on her lips I've got the original
ready down here for comparison let's hit
create
and there we are and that is actually
not bad at all in fact I think it's
pretty hard to tell which one is the
original and which one is my creation
that is a good likeness of the Mona Lisa
now in a way I've been quite lucky here
you do have to work quite a bit with
image prompts if you've got a really
exact idea of what you want and it does
all just come down to being descriptive
and being detailed and you'll be really
surprised actually by how much open AI
knows about Styles you can talk about
impressionism or the style of Matisse or
Picasso you can talk about different
lights Shades and Hues you can talk
about anime and manga just go into as
much detail about the image as you want
to now I'm going to leave you to play
with this hopefully you can describe a
few more famous paintings you might even
do better than I've done and you're
ready go back to the app we're going to
put these image generating skills to
good use perhaps not quite in the way
you'd expect us to actually all will be
revealed in the next scrim
foreign
image to complement our synopsis and
title these ones from Jaws and Star Wars
are really really cool and in an Ideal
World we too could have cover art that
featured our star-studded cast and had
the title of the film right there
blazing across the cover now
unfortunately open AI is not going to
generate recognizable famous faces for
us and also it can't reliably add text
to images so what we're going to do
instead is focus on illustrating aspects
of the plot we can still create some
funky images and the app is going to end
up looking something like that now we
know how to get images and what we could
do quite easily is just come down here
and add an input field to the app and
have our users write an image prompt but
the whole point of AI is that it's labor
saving so what we want to do is actually
use the title and synopsis to generate
an image prompt for us and that is a key
power of AI you can use what you've
generated to generate something else so
it's a kind of chain reaction now we're
going to use two functions to do this
the first function is going to generate
the prompt and the second function is
going to use that prompt to generate an
image
so I'm going to come down here and set
up a new function called Fetch image
prompt now fetch image prompt should
take in both the title and the synopsis
and I'm going to call this function from
the fetch title function that we've got
right here fetch title takes in the
synopsis and it gets us the title and so
what I think we'll do to keep things a
bit tidy is actually set up the title on
a const right here because we're
actually going to use the title twice
we'll use it to update the Dom and now
we'll use it when we call the fetch
image prompt function
so we'll pass in title and synopsis
okay now before we generate any images
we should actually check in the console
what prompt we get back to make sure
it's good so for now I'm just going to
log out the prompt that this function
generates
and now of course we need to build the
AI call and again I'm going to do most
of the heavy lifting before I set you
the challenge for the prompt writing so
we're using the same model I've left the
prompt blank for now and I've set max
tokens to 100 which should be easily
enough and now let me paste in a
challenge
okay so this is your challenge I want
you to write a prompt that will generate
an image prompt that we can use to get
the artwork for our movie idea open AI
has no knowledge of our characters of
course so the image prompt needs
descriptions not names what do I mean by
that well if we have a character in The
synopsis called Katie and maybe she's
the protagonist and our image prompt
says Katie is standing in front of a
burning building well of course the
image API has no idea who Katie is no
idea what she looks like so what we need
is a description of Katie and what she's
doing so maybe how tall she is what
she's wearing perhaps she's carrying an
ax or some other weapon and is standing
in front of a burning building I've set
this as quite an open Challenge and
deliberately so I want you to do some
experimentation here but I will say that
you might find it best to use examples
so I have put some examples I up here in
this examples dot MD file but do of
course feel free to write your own
examples or go online and find some
synopsis and titles of your favorite
films and perhaps you can use them as
well okay pause now get this challenge
sorted and I'll see you back here in
just a moment
okay hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so let's come in here and
start working on the prompt I'm going to
start off with an instruction I'm going
to say give a short description of an
image which could be used to advertise a
movie based on the title and synopsis
now I'm going to add to that the
description should be rich in visual
detail but contain no names
now this second sentence may or may not
be effective openai prefers to be told
what to do not told what not to do but
I've had reasonable success with this so
I'm going to phrase it like that now I'm
going to add some examples and I
actually put three examples in the
examples.md file but I'm only going to
use two I think two is enough
so first I'll use the separator and now
I'll paste in my examples
so let's just tidy that up and add any
more separators that we need remember
what we want to do is separate the
instruction from the examples and
actually separate each example as well
and of course the important part is to
include our title our synopsis and leave
open AI a space to create the image
prompt
okay now just as I was doing that I
realized that up here I've asked for a
short description of an image which
could be used to advertise a movie based
on title and synopsis and then down here
I've used image description as two words
image description hyphenated an image
description hyphenated now open AI can
probably cope with that kind of typo but
it might be worth just looking out for
that kind of thing and just making sure
we are consistent so I'm just going to
change both of those to two words now
I'm going to put temperature to 0.8 and
I'm doing that because I found that some
of my image prompts were just a little
bit too wacky when it was left at the
default one which is the most creative
setting now it's really hard to tell
with temperature whether you're making a
big difference or not sometimes it might
just have been that the ideas that open
AI gave me at that time would just
particularly strange now it can be
really hard to tell sometimes if small
temperature changes are making much
difference it could just be that the
examples I got before happened to be
particularly strange but that said I've
tested this a few times and 0.8 seems to
be about right okay so let's hit save
and we can test it and see what we get
so I'll press send and now let's open up
the console because that is where our
image prompt is going to appear and
there we are a colorful image of a
raccoon elephant alligator and squirrel
standing in the middle of a city street
back to back facing menacingly towards
the viewer around them robotic and alien
forces March in the background weapons
drawn in the sky above a giant robot
claw looms ominously now I think that is
a really really nice image prompt now if
you approach this challenge differently
and you got different results which
you're still happy with that is
absolutely fine there is no one right
answer to this okay we've got an image
prompt so in the next scrim let's go
ahead and use it to generate an image
when you're ready let's move on
okay so it's time to get this image into
place we've generated a good prompt so
now I'm going to set up a new function
called Fetch image URL
and of course that needs to be an async
function now to fetch the URL it's going
to need a prompt and we generated The
Prompt and we've got it back in this
response right here so it's going to
take in a parameter and I'm just going
to call that parameter image prompt
now if we have a look at the HTML we can
see that down here inside the output
section we've got this div and it's got
the class of output image container and
the ID of output image container well
that is of course where we're going to
render the image so let's come back to
our function and I'm just going to add
one line of code right here
now the source of that image is actually
going to be the URL that we get back
from this fetch request to the API
so I'm actually going to leave that
empty for now because that is going to
form part of your challenge but before
we get on to that challenge there's just
a couple more bits to do I want to call
this function from inside this fetch
image prompt function so I'll do that
right here and we need to pass in our
image prompt well we've got that right
here so let's just take that and paste
it in there and I'm just going to delete
this console.log now the other thing
that I'm going to do is just comment
this line of code once again so that is
just the display none on the output
container so we'll be able to see the
image right there okay now bear with me
while I paste in your challenge so this
is your challenge use the image prompt
to generate an image the image should be
512 by 512 pixels in size we only want
one image and we want to get a URL back
from open AI think about what properties
you need to put in the object that
you're going to pass to open AI now one
word of warning if you find a lot of
garbled text in your images you could
specifically request an image with no
text and what I'm talking about is this
sometimes open AI gives you images which
you've got this garboard meaningless
text and this image has also got a
really dodgy white border so there's
literally nothing to like about it so
you could just try adding to your prompt
a sentence which says I don't want any
text in the image okay pause now if you
need to flip back to the screen before
last to refresh your memory go for it
get this challenge sorted and I'll see
you back here in just a minute
okay hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so I'm going to come in here
and I'll set up my response
and we're going to await openai dot
create image
and we know we need to pass it an object
and the first thing we'll put in that
object is a prompt
and the prompt is going to be this image
prompt parameter we've got here but I do
want to add a sentence to try and avoid
this garbled text on the image so I'm
actually going to put this in curly
braces
we'll have the dollar sign and we'll
wrap it in back ticks
and I'm just going to add there should
be no text in this image
okay next I'm going to add an N property
and we don't really need to do that
again just a reminder for you we only
want one image and that is what we'll
get by default now for the image size we
wanted 512 by 512
and the response format will default to
URL anyway but let's just write it out
and all we need to do now then is deal
with what we get back and we're going to
put it right here inside the source for
this image and in fact I'm just going to
delete this challenge text so we've got
a little bit more space so the image
element is already inside backticks so I
can come in here with the dollar sign
and the curly braces
and it will be response.data.data
and I'll just close the mini browser
because this is getting kind of long and
we actually want the element at position
zero
and from the object stored there we want
the URL now when you tried that it
should have worked perfectly as I said
before I can't use this format in the
scrimber recorder because the image will
have disappeared by the time you
actually get to watch this so I'm going
to make a couple of changes here I'm
going to change this to b64 underscore
Json
and I'm also going to go for a slightly
smaller image because actually the
encoded images are quite big it's a
little bit overwhelming for the mini
browser which can actually crash
sometimes if you give it too much data
so I'm just going to go for the 256.
a little bit more to do I just need to
tell the browser that this image is
coming in a data format and I also need
to update this it won't be a URL
property it will be b64 underscore Json
okay let's hit save and let's put a one
sentence outline right here and it's one
we've seen before it's the time traveler
going back to the 80s and falling in
love let's hit send
okay and we have our image now the first
thing to mention is this is a little bit
small because I've gone for a smaller
image size so I'm just going to make a
little tweak to the CSS I'm going to
come in here where we've got the output
image container and we're looking for an
image within that container and I'm just
going to change Max width to width
okay so everything is working we've got
a title we've got an image we've got
some stars and we've got a synopsis so I
think what we need to do now is put that
to display none and we just need to make
a few little updates to the ux now if
you'll recall what we want to happen at
the end is that we get this view pitch
button which will then display whatever
open AI has given us so what I'm going
to do is come down here into this
function and we're going to add some
more logic right here and the first bit
of logic is just going to take this
container that we've got here which is
currently holding the text area where we
write and then this loading SVG and it's
just going to replace it with this pink
button so let's go ahead and put that
right in here
now the next thing we need to do is
actually wire up this button so I'm
going to set up an event listener right
here
and what we'll do then is we'll set the
setup container to display none
so that's the entirety of this section
right here so that is this entire white
container you see in the mini browser so
let's take control of that container
and then we'll access its style and
display and we'll set that To None next
we want to take the output container
which is this one right here and that is
the one which is set to display none by
default in the CSS and we want that set
to display Flex
now while we're here I think we should
actually quickly update the message that
we get from the movie boss at the very
end he should make some outrageous Claim
about his own ability and ask for some
money so we've already selected the
movie boss text
so let's set the inner text of that
to the following he's going to say this
idea is so good I'm jealous it's gonna
make you rich for sure remember I want
ten percent okay now for the moment of
truth let's see the whole thing in
action
I'm going to say a pizza delivery Rider
infiltrates and organized crime group
let's hit save and cross our fingers so
we get the first message we get the
personalized response
now we've got the view pitch button and
we're getting an error I've made a
really silly mistake you can probably
see what it is just pause now and debug
that
okay so you've probably noticed I've
actually forgotten to put the inverted
commas around these two let's try that
again
there's the first message
and here is the view pitch button and
there we are we have got our image we
have got pizza delivery man the Loire
Vitale story okay that sounds pretty
classy is John Travolta and Uma Thurman
that's a pretty good mix if you like
Quentin Tarantino films and let's check
out the synopsis
and actually that synopsis is pretty
cool I would go and see that movie okay
so everything is working so let's just
take one more scrim to recap what we've
done with this project and where you can
go from here
congratulations on finishing movie Pitch
now you've got all of the foundations
you need to work with the open AI API in
your apps let's just quickly recap what
we've studied so we set up the open AI
API and you can see that right here on
lines one to eleven and we used the text
DaVinci 003 model with the create
completions endpoint and you can see
that down here on lines 25 and 26. now
we started off using the zero shot
approach so we made a simple prompt
request to the API with just a one-line
instruction we then upgraded that to the
few shot approach with multiple examples
and we can see that right here lines 27
down to 39 and we used the few shot
approach to demonstrate to the API what
sort of completion we were looking for
we also used the max tokens property and
you can see that right here we did that
to ensure the model had enough tokens to
answer the queries successfully and of
course we also use the temperature
setting and we can see that down here on
line 70 and that alters how daring our
completions were higher temperatures
allowed open ai's Virtual imagination to
go into overdrive and lower temperatures
kept things safer and more predictable
now finally if we come down here we can
see that we have got a slightly
different endpoint in use right here
it's the create image endpoint and we
used it to generate images from text
prompts so wow that was quite a lot now
it's always a good idea to make a
project your own and there are multiple
ways that you could take this project to
the next level here are just a few ideas
so in terms of the JavaScript at the
moment we're making a lot of API calls
to the same endpoint I wonder if you
could find a way to think dry do not
repeat yourself and have one function do
the calling so we don't repeat the same
line of code like this one that you see
right here multiple times
so that would just involve a bit of neat
refactoring now in terms of the AI if
you want to get anywhere in Hollywood or
Bollywood you're going to need a script
and The Logical next step of this
project is to have open AI create a
script for your movie now that is a
little bit tricky in terms of the amount
of tokens you'd have to use so you would
have to break the process up into chunks
but it is doable and then you could
perhaps use the create image endpoint to
create more detailed character sketches
or you could tailor the app to a more
specific genre so have it create
specifically manga or rom-coms now if
you take these three ideas and sell the
script I want five percent now
ultimately the best way to consolidate
your learning is to delete all of the
code and start again from scratch you
can use it to practice your HTML CSS
JavaScript and your knowledge of the
open AI API now of course you wouldn't
need to do it exactly the same way you
would do it as you think best and just
justify the changes you make so quite a
lot of potential work to do there but
with the skills you've got all of this
is possible now whatever you do make
sure you take a break now and
consolidate what you've learned before
moving on to the next project
it's official chat Bots are taking over
the world loads of sites have them and
since the arrival of the more advanced
chat GPT models like text DaVinci 003
are now gpt4 the model we're about to
use chat Bots are going to Skyrocket
even more and as they are one of the
most common uses for AI in web dev this
course wouldn't be complete without one
so we're going to build a chatbot using
GPT for the latest openai model at the
time of recording and it looks like this
know it all does exactly what it says it
answers your questions and Converses
with you at a human level you can ask it
anything and it will do its best to
answer now I need to say a quick word
about gpt4 at the time of recording you
have to join a waiting list to get your
hands on the gpt4 API now I'm sure that
will change in time but if you haven't
got gpt4 API access now you can click on
this slide it's a link which will will
take you to the waiting list sign up
page now if you don't have access to the
gpt4 API yet no problem everything we do
will work with the GPT 3.5 turbo model
and this is also a very very capable
model so just take a note of that right
now if you don't have the gpt4 API yet
and then wherever in the course we use
gpt4 you can use GPT 3.5 turbo instead
and then when you get the gpt4 API
access you can just swap out GPT 3.5
turbo for gpt4 as I'll be using in this
project so what exactly are we going to
study well we'll take our knowledge from
the previous project and we're going to
add in the chatbot specific syntax used
by gpt4 and the GPT 3.5 turbo models the
syntax is exactly the same and it will
work with both models just fine we'll
also look at how you can instruct the
chatbot to behave in a particular way a
or have a specific personality and then
we'll look at something called presence
penalty which can control How likely the
chatbot is to talk about new topics and
we'll also look at something called
frequency penalty which can control how
repetitive the chatbot is in its choice
of words and phrases and finally we'll
change direction and look at how we can
store our conversation in a database so
it persists even if a user reloads the
page or closes their browser now I just
want to give you a quick warning again
that at the moment our API key is
visible on the front end so be sure to
keep it safe don't share it and make
sure you ignore the end file if you're
publishing to a repo
okay that's enough chat from me I've
already got some HTML and CSS prepared
for this project so let's take a look at
that and then get this chat bot working
let's take a look at the code we've
already got we've got a form component
right here and a button which inside a
form component will act as a submit
button now this div up here this is
where the conversation unfolds and in it
we've got this one hard-coded message
how can I help you and that is the
message that we can see right here
now over in index.js we've got exactly
the same setup as before these lines of
code right here are the open AI setup
just like they were in the previous
project and remember in terms of the API
key that we're bringing in from this dot
m file we will be looking at deploying
projects with API Keys hidden towards
the end of the course and always be sure
not to expose your API key when you're
deploying projects sharing them or
publishing them to public repositories
now here we've taken control of the chat
bot conversation div and we can see that
right here in the HTML this is the ID
right here so it's referring to this div
and that is the div where the
conversation takes place now we've got
that stored in this const and I've
declared that globally as we'll need to
use it in multiple functions
now moving on down we've got this event
listener and it is listening out for any
submit event and that will be triggered
by your user clicking on the button or
pressing enter to submit the form when a
submit event is detected we build a new
element with create elements we then add
the necessary CSS classes and append it
to the chat bot conversation div then we
populate it with whatever the user has
inputted and at that point we can go
ahead and clear the input field now this
line of code right here just moves the
dialog down so the latest messages are
always in view else as the conversation
grows you'd keep having to scroll down
manually now this is quite a neat way of
doing it but you could also use scroll
into view but I found when you're
running a mini browser in a big browser
that can sometimes fail so I went for
this approach finally we have this
render typewriter text function as the
name suggests it will give a typewriter
effect to the ai's text as it is
rendered now there are loads of ways to
do typewriter text some you can do just
with CSS but I've gone for a JavaScript
approach and what happens in this
function is again we create a new
element we add the necessary CSS classes
this one includes a blinking cursor
class which will just give a nice
blinking cursor effect to the text as
it's rendered and in fact you can see
the CSS for that right at the end of the
CSS file we've got the animation right
there the speed at which each individual
character is rendered is controlled by
this set interval and at the moment I've
got it set to 50 milliseconds and you
can of course change that if you would
prefer a different speed now we won't be
working much with the rest of the CSS in
this file but do pause and check it out
if you'd like to there's nothing
particularly special going on but we
have got a bit of CSS grid up here where
we deal with the chat bot header so the
CSS grid is just used for this layout up
here okay so that is what we have so far
let's move on and take an overview of
how the AI is going to work in this
project it's a little bit different to
what we've done so far so let's look at
that next
okay let's take an overview of how the
gpt4 model works with chat bots so we're
going to use one function to make
requests to the API and in a
conversation we'll use that function
multiple times but we need to think
about what we send in the prompt because
there's actually a big problem for chat
Bots that we have to overcome and I want
to illustrate that for you right here so
what I've got here is a simple call to
the API using the create completion
endpoint and the text DaVinci 003 model
which is the model we used in the
previous project and I chose it here
because it should look pretty familiar
by now and I can use it to illustrate
the point that I want to make about chat
Bots without getting caught up in new
syntax we haven't studied yet now I'm
going to come in here to this prompt and
I'm going to ask a question
where were the 2001 Wimbledon Tennis
Championships held okay let's call that
function
and we'll hit save and open up the
console
and we get the answer the 2001 Wimbledon
Tennis Championships were held at the
all England lawn tennis and croquet Club
in Wimbledon London England okay so it's
a correct answer now let's ask it who
won that year
and I'll hit save and it tells us the
Philadelphia 76ers won the 1982 NBA
championship and this is what's called a
hallucination the AI makes up a
linguistically plausible answer when it
doesn't know the right answer and we'll
talk more about hallucinations later in
this course now it figures that it
doesn't know the answer the question who
won it that year only makes sense in the
context of the previous question which
had the keywords Wimbledon and 2001 and
that exposes a big problem for chat Bots
which is that models have no memory of
past completions and that means that all
relevant information must be sent with
each API request so I need to refactor
my second question to include all of the
information that the model needs to know
I.E who won Wimbledon
in 2001. let's run that
and it says gorani venicevich won
Wimbledon in 2001 and that is true with
the only problem being that it's assumed
I was talking about the men's
championships the women's championships
were won by Venus Williams that year and
she beat the Belgian Justine enan in
three sets so there's just a little
example of the biases picked up by AI
models as their fed data from the open
internet okay so when it comes to chat
bots in order for the model to interact
properly so the conversation flows and
remains logical the model needs to know
the context of the conversation and we
achieve that by sending the conversation
as it exists so far with each request so
let's look at a diagram of how the main
AI business logic is going to work with
this chatbot
so the first thing that we'll need to do
is store the conversation in an array
and that is what's represented here by
this box and this does have to be an
array the gpt4 model and the endpoint
we're going to be using have much
stricter rules and syntax than the text
DaVinci 003 model and the create chat
completion endpoint now once we've set
up this array we'll use some special
open AI syntax to instruct the chatbot
and tell it how we want it to behave and
then we'll store that instruction in an
object at the first index of the array
and I've just put the curly braces
either side of instructions just to make
it clear that that will be an object and
that this is an array of objects so now
we've got the instructions at the first
index of the array we will take some
input from the user and the first thing
to do with that input is to render it to
the Dom then we'll use some open AI
syntax to format it and again we'll save
it in an object in conversation array
once that's done we're going to send the
entire conversation array off to the
open AI API and what we'll get back of
course is the response and what we'll
need to do then is render the completion
to the Dom and then place the completion
in an object with the correct syntax
that we'll be discussing shortly and
then we'll be adding it to conversation
array so right now conversation array
has got three objects we've got the
instructions the user's input and the
first response from the API and then as
you can imagine this process continues
we take the user's reply we render it to
the Dom we place it in an object we
store that object in conversation array
and then we send it off to the API we
get back our response and we render it
to the Dom place it in an object and
then store the object in conversation
array and that process continues with
the user's response and we just keep
repeating as needed and this can go on
and on until you reach the token limit
but the token limit with the gpt4 model
is extremely generous so it would have
to be a very very long conversation
indeed to reach that limit okay that's
the overview let's get to work
okay so we need a place to store our
conversation this is going to be the
single source of Truth as it were the
place where everything we ask of open Ai
and everything it replies to us is
stored so I'm going to come in here and
I'm going to set up a const called
conversation array
and in fact I'll abbreviate array to
just r
and remember this is going to store an
array because the API needs to have this
conversation as an array of objects
so let's look at the first object that
we need it's the object that holds the
instruction this is where we tell the
chat bot how we want it to behave now
this instruction object consists of two
key value Pairs and that will be the
same for all of the objects in this
array they're going to follow a similar
pattern the first key will be roll and
this should correspond to the value
system this is just telling open AI that
what comes next is the instruction and
not part of the conversation the second
key will be content and this should
correspond to a string with an
instruction and this is your chance to
influence how the AI behaves and
responds so I'm going to come in here
and I'll set up the first object in this
array
so the first key will be roll
and we'll set that to the string system
and the second key will be content and
this will hold our instruction and for
now I'm going to put something fairly
mainstream
I've gone for you are a highly
knowledgeable assistant that is always
happy to help now later on in the
project when the chat bot is up and
running we will actually revisit this
instruction and have some fun with it
but for now let's keep things simple
Okay so we've got the conversation array
and the instruction object set up now
let's deal with the user's inputted text
which we'll also be adding to this
conversation array so let's come on to
that next
okay so we have the instructions object
in the array and now we need to add the
user's input so in index.js we've got
this event listener listening out for a
submit and when it detects the submit
the anonymous function takes the user's
input and saves it to this const user
input so what we need to do is take that
incoming text and put it into an object
and push it to conversation array now
we've already seen how the chat GPT
model wants its objects and we've got an
example of it right here we've got an
object with two key value pairs role and
content and what we're going to do next
is actually very very similar the object
is going to have two key value pairs the
first key will be roll and this should
correspond to the value user the second
key will be content and this should
correspond to a string holding whatever
the user has inputted so right here in
provide the event listeners Anonymous
function I have written you a challenge
I want you to push an object holding the
user's input to conversation array and
then just log out conversation array to
check it's worked now I'm going to leave
this slide right here so you know
exactly what that object should hold
okay pause now get that sorted and I'll
see you back here in just a moment
okay so hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so I'm going to come in here
and I'm going to say conversation array
and I'll use dot push
and we're going to push an object and we
know the first key will be roll
and that will have the value of the
string user
the second key will be content
and that will hold whatever the user has
inputted okay now let's log out
conversation array and see if it's
worked
so I'll open up the console and I'll ask
a question
and there we are we are logging out
conversation array and you can see that
we've got two objects the first object
has got the role of system and the
content with our instruction these
second object has got the role of user
and the content what is your name which
is the question that I just asked okay
so that is perfect we have got the
conversation array growing we've got the
instructions object we've got the user's
inputted text and the next step of the
process is to send it all off to the
open AI API so in the next scrim let's
look at how we actually use the create
chat completions endpoint which is just
a little bit different to the previous
endpoints we've used
Okay so we've got our conversation so
far and it consists of two objects the
instructions object and the user input
object so let's work on sending them off
to the API
so back in index.js then when the event
listener detects a submit let's call a
function called Fetch reply
and I'll come down here and set the
function up
and because this function will be
calling the API this will be an async
function
next let's store the response to a const
and await the API call
now so far at this point we've been
using the create completion and create
image endpoints but now we're going to
use something different let's head over
to the API docs and see what we can find
and this slide is of course a link to
those docs what I'm looking at here is
the API reference for create chat
completion and there's a ton of info on
this page and we will be investigating
it more soon but I want to focus in on
the code example they give us right here
and specifically this it says openai dot
create chat completion okay let's go
back to the code and we're going to add
create chat completion right here
and just like with the other endpoints
we're going to pass it an object
so in the next Grim let's head back to
the docs and investigate what
information this endpoint needs from us
okay so let's complete the object we're
going to send to the API if we go back
to the docs we can see that two
properties are required they are the
model and messages now so far for the
model we've been using text DaVinci 003
which is a very capable model but now
we're going to use gpt4
gpt4 is the newest and most impressive
open AI model yet it makes huge
improvements on its predecessors and
that is why everyone's been talking
about it now if you're looking at these
docs and thinking wait there it says GPT
3.5 turbo here yes the gpt4 model is
fresh out at the time of recording and
these docs need updating so if you click
through to these docs you might find
they look a bit different now let's just
click through to this endpoint
compatibility table we can see that gpt4
is listed under chat completions so this
is going to work just fine
now for the messages property slightly
confusingly the example they've given
here is a bit of a simplification so I'm
going to ignore that and click through
to chat format
here we can see the format that it wants
and hopefully that looks familiar it's
an array with objects and each object
has got two key value pairs role and
content and this is exactly what we have
in conversation array we've got an array
of objects and each object has got two
key value pairs with role and content
and if we look closer here we can see
that the first object has the role of
system and the content is an instruction
so in the object we send to the API our
messages property just needs to hold
conversation array so just to recap the
object we sent to the API will have two
properties model which is gpt4 and
messages which should hold conversation
array and you can think of messages as
being a replacement for the prompt
property that we used in the previous
project
okay so let's do this as a challenge and
we're working here inside fetch reply
and inside the object that we're going
to send to the API I want you to give
this object a model property of gpt4
give it a messages property which should
hold our conversation array and then ask
a question hit send and log out the
response to see if it works
now just before you do that you might
have noticed that I'm not nudging you to
include a Max tokens property in the
past we found that Max tokens defaulted
to 16 that was when we were using the
text DaVinci 003 model on the create
completions endpoint on the create chat
completions endpoint things are
different because we're building up the
conversation and sending it with every
request trying to define a single Max
tokens figure is impossible and in fact
the default with gpt4 is much higher
anyway so it's not going to cause a
problem
okay code up this object and then we'll
have a look together
okay so hopefully you got that working
just fine so this should be quite
straightforward the model is gpt4
and of course that is in a string
and the messages are conversation array
let's just come down here and log out
the response
and I'll hit save and I'm going to ask
it a question
I've asked what is the capital of
Tunisia and we've got a response and I'm
just going to copy that response and
paste it into the editor so we can see
it really clearly
we've got loads of info here just like
before but the important bit is right
here with the content the capital of
Tunisia is Tunis so we have successfully
made our first request to the gpt4 model
okay next we need to use this response
in two ways we need to update the Dom
and we need to update the conversation
array so let's look at that next
we need to update the Dom and we need to
update conversation array so we're going
to go straight into a challenge and I've
got the challenge right here we're
working inside the fetch reply function
so I want you to pass the completion to
the render typewriter text function so
it updates the Dom and we've got the
render typewriter text function right
here and it takes in a parameter
now once you've done that push an object
to conversation array this object should
have a similar format to the object we
pushed in line 21 but the role should
hold the string assistant and the
content should hold the completion we
get back from the API let's just have a
quick look at line 21 here it is it's
actually line 22 we're pushing this
object it's got the role of user and the
content is the user input.value so the
object that we pushed to conversation
array is going to have a very similar
format
now once you've done that you can log
out conversation array to check it's
working and of course you should see the
Dom updated by the render typewriter
text function now I've given you a big
hint here to save yourself some time and
work have a close look at the response
before tackling number two and I've
actually left the response that we
logged out in the last scrim right here
because that will help you okay pause
now get this challenge sorted and I'll
see you back here in just a moment
okay hopefully you got that working just
fine so I'm going to come in here and
I'll call the render typewriter text
function and what do we need to pass it
well if we come down to this response we
can see that we've got the actual
completion right here and we can access
that by saying response dot data and we
want what we've got at the zero index of
that array and then we want to access
the content in that object so quite a
convoluted line of code but let's just
write all of that in here so it's
response.data.choices
then we want the element at position
zero
then we want to access the message
property
and then the content
okay next let's push an object to
conversation array
now luckily and it's what I was getting
at with this hint I don't actually need
to build an object if we have a look
again down at the response let's see
what we've got right here well we've got
an object and it's got two key value
pairs role and content the role is
assistant and the content is the
completion so that is exactly what we
want already formatted
so I hope you noticed that and you
didn't extract the text and then write
the code to build a new object
okay so back up here we're taking almost
everything that we've got here but
because we want the whole object we'll
take away the dot content
and now let's just log out conversation
array I'll hit save and let's ask a
question
what is the currency of Peru
and we've got an answer the currency of
Peru is the Peruvian Soul that's great
fantastic answer and if we open up the
console and have a look we can see
conversation array and it's got three
objects in it the instruction the user
inputted text and now the object with
the completion we've just got back from
the API okay so our chat bot is
essentially working now I just want to
ask it a couple of questions what I'm
Keen to see is is it keeping the context
of the conversation does it have a
memory that it's getting from our
conversation array so I'm going to ask
it for pi
okay and it's given me a very long
answer all I really wanted was the
number
3.14159 but that's good because now I
can check its memory I'm going to say
give it to me to three decimal places
and what's interesting to see here is
does it understand it to be Pi which we
were just talking about if it does it's
got a memory and it's keeping the
context of the conversation let's find
out
and there we are pi to three decimal
places is 3.142 so it has a memory and
that is exactly what we want from a chat
bot Okay so we've pretty much nailed the
chat bot or at least its Basics so let's
take a look at a few more tweaks we can
make to really level up our chatbot
skills now one danger you can run into
with chat Bots is that they can get
repetitive no one likes the conversation
with someone that just says the same
thing over and over so let's take a look
at how we can deal with that next
at the moment we're only using two
properties when we make a request to the
API we're using the model and the
messages and they are both required now
in the previous project we used Max
tokens which as I said is not so helpful
here and we also use temperature which
you're welcome to add if you think your
chat bot is not performing optimally you
can just go ahead and add it right here
and just like with the DaVinci model it
defaults to one now I don't think we
need to change the temperature on this
so I'm actually going to delete that
what I do want to look at though is two
settings frequency penalty and presence
penalty and what they do is offer some
control over how repetitive our output
is because we want the language to sound
natural and we don't want to find
ourselves saying can you stop saying
that now we're going to look at these
two settings together as they are
similar and they're easy to confuse so
let's take presence penalty first
presence penalty will be a number from
-2 to 2 and you can change it in
increments of 0.01 it defaults to zero
so that is what we're using now because
it's unset at higher numbers presence
penalty increases the model's likelihood
of talking about new topics so what does
that mean in the real world well let's
imagine a conversation between two
friends and this conversation is taking
place at low presence penalty so one
friend says hey give me some good news
and the other friend says Manchester
United won six nil it was the best game
ever I've never seen Real Madrid fans
looking so unhappy Manchester United are
the best let me tell you about the game
in detail
hmm we all know someone like that right
now what would happen to this
conversation if we could flip it to a
high presence penalty the first friend
says hey give me some good news and the
reply is well my team won on Saturday my
investments are doing well my brother's
out of Hospital the Sun's shining and
I'm getting married next June so you can
see that instead of obsessing over
Manchester United they're actually
talking about more topics okay let's
compare that to frequency penalty these
settings are very similar it's a number
from minus two to two and you can change
it in increments of 0.01 it also
defaults to zero at higher numbers it
decreases the model's likelihood of
repeating the exact same phrases okay
let's again imagine a conversation
between two friends and this will take
place at low frequency penalty so the
first friend says hey how was your week
and the reply is I went to a literally
unbelievable part there were literally
millions of people trying to get in Brad
Pitt was there and I spent literally the
whole evening with him me and Brad are
literally best friends now and we've all
met that person right the one who says
literally a lot or basically or you know
what I mean okay if we repeat that at a
high frequency penalty hey how was your
week I went to an amazing party there
were literally thousands of people
trying to get in Brad Pitt was there and
I spent the whole evening with him me
and Brad are best friends now same
unbelievable story but the word
literally has been used only once so the
frequency penalty will allow the word to
be used but it will stop it being
overused okay that's the theory in the
next Grim let's get practical
okay so the conversation we looked at in
the previous scrim was of course Very
contrived actually president's penalty
is a very subtle setting and it can be
hard to see it in action in fact it's
only really noticeable when you're
generating large amounts of text so
rather than watch me churning out loads
of text you're going to have to do some
investigation on your own so I'm going
to come in here and I'm going to set
presence penalty to zero
and that is of course its default
setting and now I want you to spend some
time experimenting so you could just
have a general chat with the chat bot at
different presence penalty settings but
it's likely better if you ask it
something that will generate a long
answer it's only then that you'll really
see president's penalty in action so
here are some ideas if you're a glass
half full kind of person you could ask
it to tell you what is great and
wonderful about the world and if you're
a glass half empty person you could ask
it to tell you what is wrong and
terrible about the world either way use
the same prompt two or more times but
with different presence penalty settings
and see what you get and if you don't
notice too much don't worry this is a
subtle setting and at least now you know
it's there so if you do have problems in
this area down the line you'll know what
to do okay take some time to do that now
and then when you're ready in the next
scrim we'll look at frequency penalty
okay let's do some experimentation
together with frequency penalty and
let's remind ourselves first what
frequency penalty is supposed to do we
use a high frequency penalty to decrease
the model's chances of repeating the
same phrases so what I'm going to do is
set you a challenge which will involve
generating some text which is likely to
have some repeated words and phrases now
because we're going to generate a lot of
text and it will actually be pretty
painful to watch the render typewriter
text function trundle through all of it
I've actually commented out that
function call right here and I've
replaced it with this console.log so we
can just log out the completion
now I've also put a file up here called
output.md and we can paste our
completions in there and save them for
comparison so here is your challenge I
want you to set the frequency penalty to
zero
give the chatbot this query generate 20
ways to say you can't buy that because
you're broke
paste the results into output.md and
then repeat that process with frequency
penalties set to 2. once you've done
that you can examine the differences
between the two outputs and see what
frequency penalty is doing now I've just
put a warning here do not set frequency
penalty to minus two and I've said that
because it actually breaks things quite
spectacularly it will just churn out the
same word again and again and again
until all of the tokens it's allowed
have been used up and in fact it will
probably crash the mini browser okay
pause now have a go at that challenge
I'm going to go through the same process
and we'll have a look at the two
completions and compare them
okay so hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so I'm just going to quickly
go through that process and paste my
completions into output.md
foreign
s and if we compare them side by side
well they both start Okay so we've got
our frequency penalty zero your
financial situation doesn't permit you
to make that purchase and then
unfortunately your funds are
insufficient for buying that item both
of those are fine both great English
let's have a look at the first two that
we've got when frequency penalty was set
to two unfortunately your Current
financial situation doesn't allow for
that purchase it seems your wallet is
feeling a bit light to acquire that item
okay a little bit quirky but no problem
now let's come to the very end because
it's the last part that's going to be
most difficult when the frequency
penalty is high now number 20 here was
with your financial setting it's
infeasible to add that to your
possessions well that's okay it's
correct English it's a little bit
strange now down here we've got monetary
scarcity dictates through reality and
discipline despite passions give Merit
where it's due nullifying all impulses
towards luxury at least for now I can't
decide if that's poetry or gibberish I
think it's just gibberish and actually
if we look a little bit further up we
can see that by setting the frequency
penalty High we've really caused open AI
problems because this is the first time
that we're actually seeing bad English
we're actually getting completions that
don't seem like they come from a human
take for example number 17. it's
apparent after analyzing existing
revenue streams financing this dream can
simply just about only be squeezed from
another worldly Dimension entirely
don't know what that means on number 18
Empty Pockets rarely find footing when
chasing certain Ambitions in our
material world might as well try
catching Stardust instead again kind of
poetic but these weird little mistakes
as well there's a comma there but no
space now one other thing I want to show
you is this I'm just going to highlight
every instance of the word Financial
now we can see if I scroll down that
word appears seven times but five of
those times are when frequency penalty
was set to zero and only two of them
were when it was set to two so that
shows us that the frequency penalty is
penalizing the word Financial it's only
letting it appear twice and when we're
talking about money it is quite an
important word let's do the same thing
with the word purchase
again the word purchase is used seven
times five times with frequency penalty
of zero and just twice with frequency
penalty set to two so we can really see
why the model is struggling to generate
new language okay so what is the bottom
line well here is my general advice for
presence penalty and frequency penalty
and I'm going to express this as a
flowchart firstly ask yourself is there
a problem if the answer is no do nothing
if the answer is yes then my advice is
this don't go over one for either
setting don't go under one for either
setting you can experiment outside of
those parameters but I would recommend
staying inside them else you run the
risk of getting some pretty strange
results and lastly it's all about making
small changes and testing if you just
make a small change and test you'll very
quickly find these settings which work
for you and get you the results you want
so what are we going to do in this app
well I'm going to leave presence penalty
at zero I don't think it's doing too
much for us anyway and frequency penalty
I'm going to put to 0.3
and I'm going to do that just because
I've had a play around with this for a
long time and I think that is where we
get the best results
you of course are free to differ okay so
the chat bot is working pretty well so
next I want to go back to where we
started to this instruction right here
and have a bit of fun with it and just
see how we can alter the chatbots
personality and why that might be useful
when you're ready for that let's move on
let's have some fun and change the
chatbots personality so here's a
challenge for you update the content
properties value to change the chat box
personality so you just need to alter
this string right here you could ask it
to be cheeky or funny or talk in Rhyme
or go for something practical maybe you
want a shorter answer or even a one-word
answer I'll leave that up to you pause
now and have a go
okay hopefully you managed to get a good
effect now I'm British we love sarcasm
so I'm going to make this a sarcastic
chat bot
and let me ask it something
and there we are it's had a pretty good
effect it says you should definitely go
to the most boring place on Earth your
local park why explore beautiful beaches
breathtaking Mountain Landscapes or
exotic cities with Rich culture when you
could just sit on a bench and watch the
grass grow sounds like a dream vacation
okay that's pretty sarcastic and I like
it but actually there is a more serious
side to this as well because we can
actually get the chatbot to behave
exactly as we want it to perhaps you
want a chatbot that's going to interact
with children perhaps you want a chatbot
that's going to interact with people for
whom English or whichever language
you're working in is not their first
language so you might want it to
simplify the language a little bit and
perhaps you don't want such long answers
we have actually got some quite long
answers so far so I might change this to
keep the answers short
and I'll ask it a big question what is
quantum computing
and look at that the most concise
definition you'll ever get Advanced
Computing using Quantum bits okay so
that's good to know you can control the
chatbot's personality and it really is
that simple
okay so we're pretty much done with the
mechanics of this chat bot what I want
to do next is use a Google Firebase
database so we can persist the chats
even when we refresh and reload let's do
that next
okay so we're going to add a Google
Firebase database to this project so we
can persist the chat now what does that
mean well let's check our specific aims
we want to persist the chat so that a
user can pick up where they left off
after a refresh or reload so the
conversation will be stored in the
database and the user can close the page
turn off their laptop and come back and
continue the conversation at a later
date
we want to give the user the ability to
reset the chat so they should be able to
delete the conversation and start a
fresh conversation from the beginning so
how is this going to work let's take a
look at a diagram at the moment all of
our code is on the front end and we've
got an array holding our conversation we
send that off to open Ai and it sends us
back a response what we're going to do
now is remove the array where we store
the conversation on the front end we're
going to create a database and we're
going to store the conversation array in
that database
when we need it we'll bring it down to
the front end and use it when we make
calls to the open AI API to start this
off we need a Google Firebase account
and we need to set up a database so
let's start doing that next
we need a Google Firebase account so
head over to the home page and actually
the image on this slide is a link click
on it and it's going to take you
straight there when you're there click
on get started and that is going to take
you to a sign up page and once you've
entered your details and set up your
account you'll end up on a page looking
like this
click create project and here we need to
give the project a name I'm going for
know it all Dash open AI but of course
you can call yours whatever you want and
now it's going to ask us if we want
Google analytics and for this project
I'm going to turn it off now hit create
project and it will take a few moments
to set things up and when it's ready you
can just click continue now we've
created our project go over to build and
then from the drop down menu select
real-time database next click create
database but if you're interested in
finding out a little bit about the
different types of database that
Firebase offers then do click this link
and that will give you a little bit more
info for this project we're using the
real-time database which is the easier
one to work with so create database and
then in the pop-up select the server
that's nearest to you I'm in the UK so
my nearest is Belgium click next and
it's going to offer us locked mode or
test mode I'm going for test mode and
that does mean that anybody with my
database reference will be able to view
edit or delete any of my data now that's
fine for the purposes of this course by
the time this gets published I will have
locked this down I recommend starting in
test mode it's just a little bit easier
to not have to deal with the security
rules at the beginning you can always
read up on that later and make some
changes to the security rules if
necessary and there we are we have our
database and the most important thing
here is this URL that is the URL we'll
be using to communicate with our
database so let me just zoom in on that
there it is I'm going to click here to
copy it and then in our code I'm just
going to create a little comment here
and paste it in and we'll use that in
the next Grim when we start adding the
Firebase setup to this code right here
in index.js
we need to add the Firebase dependency
so I'm going to come over here to the
three dot menu and when I click on that
a menu appears and you can't actually
see that in the recording but I'm going
to select add dependency and a pop-up
appears and I'm just going to type in
Firebase and I'll click add and we can
see that the Firebase dependency has
appeared over here on the left hand side
now if you're working locally you can
install this via npm and you can check
out the Firebase docs on that right here
again this screenshot is a link just
click it to go straight through to those
docs and by the way you can also use a
CDN to work with Firebase if you prefer
to do it that way okay now we've got the
Firebase dependency setup we need to
import some methods so I'm going to come
right up here to the top and we'll say
import
and then inside curly braces I'm going
to say initialize app
and we're importing that from Firebase
slash app
next I'm going to import get database
and ref
and these are coming from Firebase slash
database
okay that's all the methods that we need
now I'm going to come down here and set
up a const called app settings
and this is going to hold an object and
it's going to have one key value pair
database URL is the key and the value
will be a string containing the URL that
we got when we set up the database and
we can delete that comment now
underneath app settings I'm going to set
up another const and this one will be
database
and here we'll use one of the methods
that we've just imported get database
next I'm going to come down here and set
up a const app
and now we will use one of the methods
that we just imported
so I'm going to say initialize app
and I'll pass in the app settings
now we need a const database
and again we'll use one of the methods
we just imported get database
and we'll pass in app and finally we'll
set up a const called conversation in
database
and I've just shortened database to DB
and we'll set that equals to ref and
we'll pass in database
so what we've just done there is set up
a const called conversation in DB and it
stores a reference to our database and
that's really important because now
conversation in DB is going to be our
single source of Truth for the
conversation we have with the chat bot
okay those are all the basic settings we
need for now we will add a few more
methods later as we go on now before we
do anything else we do need to make a
few changes to the HTML and CSS I want
to add a clear button right here so I'm
going to go over to index.html and I'll
come in here and just paste in the clear
button
and I'll hit save and of course we've
broken the CSS so let's head over to
index.css and we need to make a couple
of changes so firstly I'm going to come
down here and paste in some CSS for the
new button and as soon as I do that you
can see that things start to change over
here now I've used the selector clear
Dash BTN and if we have a quick look
back at index.html the button has
already got that class added and the
most important part of this CSS is
actually this property right here grid
area clear Dash BTN and we're using that
because the layout up here uses CSS grid
so if we come up here to the chatbot
header selector this is where we're
setting display grid and we've got the
grid template areas right here and I'm
going to change this dot for Clear BTN
and now things are starting to come into
alignment so clear BTN is the grid area
that we've got on the clear BTN selector
now we've still got a flat Edge to this
button and that's because at the moment
down on line 137 we are currently
selecting all buttons and we've got
Styles set up for this submit button
that we've got right here and the submit
button has a border left of zero now if
we go back to index.html we've got the
submit button right here and it's
actually already got a CSS class of
submit Dash BTN so how about we come
over here and we replace this with the
more specific selector
okay that has had the effect of giving
us a full rounded button which is what
we want right here now all we need to do
is bring this into alignment by coming
up to the support ID selector and taking
this property right here text align
right and changing it to Center
okay now we've got it looking how we
want it and we're good to move on next
we need to figure out how to push our
users input to the database
right here we're pushing our users input
to conversation array but now we want to
store the user's input in the database
that is going to be the single source of
Truth so let's use firebase's push
method to push it to the database
instead to get access to the push method
we need to add it to the list of imports
so I'll come up here
and add it in right there and then back
down in the event listener let's come in
here and we're going to delete
conversation array and now we've got
push and that is no longer the standard
JavaScript array method that is now the
Firebase push method and what we need to
pass it is the reference of the database
we want to add to and the reference to
that database we've got up here
it is conversation in DB so we'll say
push and then in Brackets conversation
in DB a comma and then the object which
we want to push and that is of course
exactly the same object and it's as easy
as that so now let's go ahead and type
something in here
and we'll hit send and let's take a look
at what we've got in the database and
there we are it has appeared if you log
into your real-time database you're
pretty much instantly see exactly what
we've just pushed to the database so
we've got the content hello know it all
and the role of user so that is our
object now doing that leaves
conversation array looking pretty
redundant we don't want to store our
conversation here anymore but that
leaves us with an issue we've got this
instruction object and we need to keep
it somewhere but storing it in the
database with the rest of the
conversation has actually got two
disadvantages number one if we ever want
to edit the instruction to change the
chatbots personality or behavior we'll
actually have to edit the database
directly and number two when we want to
clear the conversation we're going to
get caught up in JavaScript spaghetti
making sure we don't delete the
instruction but do delete everything
else so we'll be making work for
ourselves the solution that I think is
best is that we keep the instruction
right here in index.js where it's easily
accessible and easily editable and we
just add it to the array we're sending
to open AI with each request so what I'm
going to do is change conversation array
to instruction object
and now it's an object let's delete
these square brackets
and when we update fetch reply we'll add
this to the array we send off to the
open AI API and actually updating fetch
reply is what we need to come on to next
the next thing we need to do is make
some changes to fetch reply we know we
need to send the entire conversation
with every request to the open AI API
but now that the conversation stored on
the database we need to fetch it before
we can include it with our request and
with Firebase we do that with the get
method but before we can use the get
method we need to add it to our list of
imports so let's come up here and we'll
just put it after push now get is a
method so we'll give it the brackets and
we're going to pass in the reference to
our database just like we did with the
push method now we're going to chain a
then and here we'll have a callback
function and that function gets a
parameter snapshot
and snapshot is the data in our database
as it exists at this time now inside the
body of this function let's be safe and
use an if just to make sure a snapshot
exists
so if for example writing to the
database right here in the event
listener failed then we would want to
know about that so let's just say else
no data available because if what we
send to the open AI API is not the array
of objects it expects it's going to give
us an error anyway so it's a good idea
to check what's going on here now in
here we can make our request to the open
AI API so let's just cut and paste all
of this code and let's just format that
nicely now we're actually not quite
ready to call the API so I'm actually
going to comment out all of that code
and let's just come in here and log out
snapshot now remember we've already got
something in our database so there
should be something for us to log out so
rather than write anything more in here
and add to the database I'm just going
to call the fetch reply function now
when I hit save let's just see what we
log out well there we are we can see the
contents of our database we've got an
object it's got a Content key with hello
know it all and a roll key with user but
at the beginning it's also got a
Firebase identifier of some kind and we
don't want to be sending that to open AI
it would just really confuse it all we
want is an array of objects so let's
check what the Firebase docs say and
they talk about this Val method and it
says here it extracts a JavaScript value
from a data snapshot well that is
exactly what we want to do now if you'd
like to read out more about Val in the
Firebase docs this screenshot is a link
so just click on it and it will take you
straight there so I'm going to come in
here and where we've got snapshot I'm
going to to call Val and let's just save
and see what happens okay so on its own
it doesn't make any difference we've
still got firebase's identifier and then
our object so let's just check something
else we can use from mdn and again this
screenshot is a link to this page on mdn
now object.values let's see what it says
here it says the object.value static
method returns an array of a given
object's own innumerable string keyed
property values okay that sounds like a
bit of a mouthful but the important
thing here is it returns an array and an
array is what we want so let's just
experiment with it and see what we get
so I'll come in here and say objects dot
values and then in Brackets we'll have
our snapshot on which we've called the
Val method okay let's hit save and look
at that down in the console we have got
an array and it's got our object in it
and that is the exact correct format
that we need to send to the open AI API
but we're not quite ready to send it yet
we need to think about the instruction
so let's do a little bit more work in
Fetch reply in the next scrim
we need to get the array that we can see
in the console off to the open AI API so
I'm going to come in here and resurrect
the old conversation array
and we'll use it to store the array we
get back from the database
and then if I uncomment all of this code
we're now going to send conversation
array off to the open AI API with each
request now to check it's working I'm
going to log out the response
and I'll just take this opportunity to
delete the console.log and also the
function called to fetch reply that we
were just using as a test and now we can
give this a try but wait a second we've
actually forgotten about our instruction
object we need that in the conversation
that we send to the open AI API so we
need to include it in conversation array
and in fact you can do that as a
challenge so I'm just going to come in
here and paste the challenge right there
because that is where you'll need to
write some code
and I've just said add instruction
object to the front of conversation
array but I've put a warning here you're
going to get an error when you do this
try to debug it okay we're already
logging out the response so pause now
get this challenge sorted and I'll see
you back here in just a minute
okay hopefully you got it working so we
can do this with unshift so we'll say
conversation array Dot unshift and then
we'll pass in the instruction object
okay now let's hit save and we'll give
it a try oh but we're getting an error
and I did warn you that you would now
it's saying unexpected reserved word so
what could be the problem here well
we're using a weight here and we can
only use a weight inside an async
function and that's what we're doing is
Nick we've got async right here well
actually no because this await is inside
the Callback function that we've got
right here so that is the function that
should be async so let's delete async
from here and add it in right here okay
let's save and try again and there we
are it's working so the final thing that
we need to do with this function is
uncomment these two lines of code right
here and in the next Grim let's see what
changes we need to make to them
this line of code right here which sends
the completion to render typewriter text
is absolutely fine we don't need to
change that but here we don't want to
update conversation array remember
conversation array is now here and it
just holds the array we get back from
the database when we use this get method
our single source of Truth is on the
database so what we actually need to be
doing right here is updating the
database so here is a challenge for you
I want you to add the completion to the
database and then ask the chatbot
something to check it's working now to
complete this challenge you can look
back at the code we've already written
and remember this code here
an object which is already formatted in
the way we need it okay pause now get
this challenge done and I'll see you
back here and we'll have a look together
okay hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so we need to use the push
method
and we need to pass it the database ref
which is conversation in DB
and then we give it the object we want
to push and we can do that with this
code right here okay let's delete this
line of code
and we'll save and give it a try I'll
ask it a simple question and it's given
me a reply it's looking good let's just
see if we've successfully updated the
database so this is what we originally
had in the database we've made a few
changes to it since then and now look
we've got my question what is a Frisbee
and the answer a flying disc so the code
that we just wrote right here is
definitely working okay so things are
going well but we've got a bit of an
issue if I just refresh the mini browser
in the database we have got a whole
conversation that I don't know about as
a user it's not shown here and that's a
problem because if I now start typing a
question I'm not aware that I'm actually
continuing a conversation and in fact I
might well have forgotten what I wrote
before so that means we've got two more
jobs to do we need to render the
existing conversation out when the app
loads so the user can see what they've
already said and we also need to wire up
this start over button so that a user
can reset the conversation whenever they
want so let's start on the first task of
rendering out the conversation on load
next
we need a function that will render out
the conversation as it exists on the
database when the app loads so the user
can see what has already been discussed
now I've set you a challenge to do this
and it might seem like a big challenge
but actually this function is just going
to recycle bits of code we've already
written and it's a good opportunity for
you to get some more practice with
Firebase so the challenge is this create
a function called render conversation
from DB which will render any existing
conversation in the database now this
function should be called when the app
loads now take all the time you need to
do this there are a few things to think
about and if you need any extra help
I've created a file up here called
hint.md and it's got some tips in there
that will really help you now if you
don't want any help pause now and get
started I'm going to open hint.md so
those watching on YouTube can pause it
and read it
okay good luck with the challenge and
when you're ready I'll show you my way
okay hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so let's come down here and
set up this function now the first thing
that we need this function to do is to
get the conversation from the database
so we'll use the get method and we'll
pass in the reference to the database
we'll chain on then
and we know the Callback function here
will be an async function and it will
have the snapshot as a parameter inside
the body of this function let's use an
if to make sure the snapshot exists
because if there is no snapshot if
there's nothing in the database this
function need not do anything and now we
want to get that snapshot as an array of
objects and we can do that by saying
object.values
and we'll pass in snapshot and we'll
need the Val method now we can iterate
over that array using A4 each
and will represent each item in the
database with database object which I'll
shorten to DB obj now for each database
object we want to create a new speech
bubble and we can do that with
document.createelement and we'll create
a div now we'll need to add some classes
to that div
and that goes with every speech bubble
is just speech now the second CSS class
is dependent on whether it's a human or
the AI That's speaking so I'm going to
open up the back ticks and both classes
start with speech Dash
and now I'll use dollar sign and curly
braces
and in here we're going to use a ternary
so I'm going to say database object dot
roll and I'm going to ask if that is
triple equals to user if it is this CSS
class should be speech Dash human and if
it's not it should be speech Dash AI
okay now we need to append that speech
bubble to chatbot conversation which we
took control of right up here on line 23
and apologies in hind.md I think I said
it was line 22 but I'm sure you found it
so let's say chatbot conversation dot
appends child and the element we want to
append is new speech bubble and lastly
we need to add the text to the speech
bubble
now I did say in hint.md make sure that
a malicious user can't use this to input
JavaScript so hopefully you didn't use
inner HTML to do this text content is
secure because anything which is
inputted is just going to be passed as
text it cannot be passed as HTML with
script tags and with executable
JavaScript inside them lastly we just
want to move the conversation down so
the latest message is always in View and
we've done that several times in the app
with scrolltop and we're setting chatbot
conversation dot scrolltop equal to
chatbot conversation dot scroll hide now
to check it's working all we need to do
is call it and if we call it right there
it should run every time the app loads
let's hit save and see what happens
and there we are our conversation is
rendered so everything that we've got in
the database we can see it all right
here is now rendered automatically as
soon as we load and we can see that the
ternary has been successful because
we've got different speech bubbles
depending on whether it's the AI or the
human that has spoken okay that's a
really good job the final task then is
to wire up this start over button let's
do that in the next scrim
okay so at the moment when the page
loads the conversation as it exists in
the database renders automatically what
we want to do now is wire up this start
over button so we can clear the
conversation so I'm going to come in
here just above the last function we
wrote although it doesn't really matter
where we write this code and I'm going
to say document dot get element by ID
and I want to take control of this
button so if we just check in the HTML
quickly we've got that button right here
and it's got clear Dash BTN
now I'll add an event listener to listen
out for clicks now when a click is
detected we've got a very easy way of
clearing the database and to do that we
use the remove method now of course
before we can use the remove method we
need to import it
so let's add it to the list right here
and all we need to do with remove and
you can probably guess this by now is
pass it the database reference
now that is going to clear the database
but obviously it's not going to update
the HTML so let's add one more line and
I'll say chat bot conversation dot inner
HTML is equals to and then we just need
our hard-coded message that goes right
at the beginning of any conversation and
we can get that from the HTML here it is
right here so let's copy it and then
we'll paste it here in inverted commas
and I'm just going to bring it all onto
one line and this is a safe use of inner
HTML because this is hard-coded HTML the
user has no way to access that or update
it in any way okay let's give it a try
so I'm going to come over here and I'll
just click the start over button and
look everything disappears we're back to
our single hard-coded message now let's
check the database I've just taken a
screenshot of it so that is how it
looked before and now it's empty so this
is working and if I come in here and
I'll actually ask ask the chat bot
is this a new conversation and it says
yes I'm going to ask it a couple of
questions
now let's refresh the conversation is
there it seems to be working let's ask
it if I've already asked it some
questions
and it replies yes what did I ask you
new convo how are you questions well
yeah that's a fair summary I did ask it
is this a new conversation and how are
you and remember it's giving us very
short answers because we did leave the
instruction right up here as you're an
assistant that gives very short answers
maybe let's just change that back to you
are a helpful assistant what have I
asked you today and there we are it
knows everything I'm going to click
Start over to clear the conversation
I'll try again what have I asked you
today and look it's telling us that it
cannot recall any past interactions with
us from separate sessions and that
proves that this is working the start
over button is doing exactly what we
want it to okay so that is a really good
job congratulations on getting to the
end of this project let's just take one
last Grim to recap what we've done and
talk about where we go from here
congratulations on finishing the
know-it-all chatbot app now you have got
the foundations you need to build any
human language capable chat bot that you
want let's just recap what we've studied
we have used the gpt4 model and the
create chat completions endpoint we've
given our chatbot a personality via the
instruction object we've seen how we can
use the presence penalty setting to
encourage the chatbot to talk about new
topics and we've used frequency penalty
to control how repetitive the chatbot is
when it selects words and phrases to use
we saved our conversation as a single
source of Truth in a database so the
conversation can be persisted and the
user can come back to it and pick it up
at a later date now it's always a good
idea to really make a project your own
so why don't you give the bot a specific
function so you could tweak the AI so
that it has a specific purpose this Tech
doesn't have to be a a general purpose
chatbot it could be a coding expert a
poetry generator an academic assistant
you could use the instruction object to
train it to provide text in the specific
style and formats you need for writing
reports at work for example the only
limit is your imagination and once
you've done that you could change the
style and theme so it matches the
chatbot's new purpose and of course it's
always a good idea to build again from
scratch and if you don't need practice
with the HTML CSS and JavaScript you
could just rebuild the API specific
parts to really get that syntax to stick
in your brain it would also be good to
add some error handling we haven't
really looked at error handling in this
course we're focusing very much on the
AI but whenever you're working with apis
error handling is more than a good idea
it's essential really if you're taking
anything to production so do do a bit of
research on that but whatever you do
remember to take a break take take a bit
of time to consolidate what you've
learned before moving on to the next
project
okay so we are going to enter the
Fantastic world of fine tuning and I've
put here making AI models work for us so
what exactly do I mean by that well in
earlier projects we have used two types
of prompt we've used the zero shot where
we just give an instruction or ask a
question we've also used the few shot
approach where we give an instruction
and we use examples to demonstrate what
we're looking for now those work fine
for our purposes but they have two big
drawbacks firstly prompts have size
limits we're Limited in how much we can
include in a prompt secondly larger
prompts use more tokens so will be
expensive when scaled but there's
actually a bigger problem than that open
ai's models have been trained on text
openly available on the internet now
that's great for when you want to use
them for creativity General q a like
we've been doing with our chat Bots
translation and many other General tasks
as well but what it's not good for is
answering questions that are specific to
your circumstances so consider this you
have a company and that company has
specific policies and systems say you
have your own opening hours you might
have shipping fees a returns policy of
course you'll have contact details and
many other things besides now imagine
you ask a chat bot like the one we just
made a specific question about your
company what are you going to get back
well you're going to get hallucinations
and what are hallucinations well if the
AI doesn't know the answer it gives you
a linguistically plausible incorrect
answer so it basically goes into the
world of fantasy now though they're
improving AI models are not that good at
saying I don't know remember what these
models do is predict the likelihood of a
token or language chunk coming next and
this is one of the biggest problems with
AI when working with
so if I ask what my company's opening
hours are it will likely say something
like 9 A.M to 5 PM and closed on Sundays
just because that is a plausible answer
now fine-tuning can help with this
problem
by uploading your own data set you can
give the model the information it needs
to answer questions specific to your
situation so let's go and we're going to
start by thinking about how we can
convert our chatbot which we still have
all of the code for right here into a
finely tuned support bot for my new
company so let's check that out next
okay so for this fine tune chat bot
we're going to use a lot of the same
HTML and CSS as the previous project but
before we get to work on the AI let's
just make some quick changes to the
design so it better fits our purpose up
here I've got the new we Wing It logo
which is just drone Dash logo so let's
just swap that out right here and
because that logo is slightly smaller we
need to just make a quick change to the
CSS right here on line 54 the logo has
got a width of 45 pixels I'm going to
change that to a width of 50 pixels okay
that's looking better now back in
index.html we need to change the name
two we Wing It drones and the subheader
will now be delivery support chat
and to give us a little bit of extra
room in the header I'm just going to
bring this down to ID and let's just
update that it doesn't do anything it's
just for Aesthetics
now I'm also going to change this one
hard-coded message so now it's going to
say how can I help you with your wee
Wing It drone delivery
and lastly we should come up here and
change the title even though it doesn't
make any difference in the mini browser
okay let's save that and there we are
everything is looking fine now the rest
of the CSS and HTML is going to stay the
same but under the hood we're going to
completely change the way we use open AI
so this is we wing it an accident-prone
drone delivery company with some very
unhappy customers now we wing it needs a
way to communicate with their customers
quickly and easily so they want an AI
support bot let's just check what
exactly we're trying to achieve here we
want a chat bot with the ability to
answer questions specific to our company
if the chatbot doesn't know the answer
rather than hallucinate it should advise
the user to email or phone okay let's
crack on now we know what we're doing
and why we're doing it let's take a high
level overview of the AI process to get
an idea of how we're going to do it
so how do we get this highly tuned
chatbot off the ground let's have a
quick look at the whole process firstly
we need data this is just like the
examples we used in the few shot prompts
but it's going to be much longer and
specifically formatted so we'll be using
the CSV format or the comma separated
values format it also works in Json
format but basically at this point we
need to make sure the chat bot has got
all of the information it needs to do
its job properly now secondly as the
fine tune process takes a long time to
run we don't want errors so let's use
open ai's data preparation tool to
process our data so the format is
correct and it won't get rejected now
this is a CLI or command line interface
tool and if you haven't used the command
line before don't worry we'll go through
it step by step the third thing we need
to do is actually upload our data to
open Ai and tell it to make our
fine-tuned model again we do do this
with a CLI tool it's very quick to get
it going but it can take a long long
time for the request to be processed now
when that process ends we will have our
own special endpoint which we can then
use with our chatbot but at that point
we'll need to think about the changes we
need to make to our existing code
because to use the new model we'll have
to make some adjustments all of the code
we've got at the moment is very specific
to the gpt4 model we've been using we'll
have to change things up a little bit
here
okay so that's how it works let's make a
start on the data
okay so we need some data to fine tune
our model so let's deal with that next
and the first question is how much data
do you need to fine-tune a model well
the advice from open AI is you should
provide at least a few hundred high
quality examples ideally vetted by human
experts and what's more open AI says
increasing the number of examples is
usually the best and most reliable way
of improving performance so if you were
setting this up in the real world you
would basically grab all of your
company's support tickets and customer
service emails and anything else
relevant that you could lay your hands
on and then as open AI recommends you
would have a human check it for accuracy
and relevance now for the app we're
building today we're going to use a
relatively small amount of data but the
principle is exactly the same that is
what I want to show you the principle of
how to fine-tune data now how we format
that data is really important open AI
wants the data to be in Json L format
and the docs give us an example now Json
L is data formatted with Json on each
line each line has to be valid Json in
its own right and each line must end
with a new line character now if you
haven't used Json L before don't worry
we won't be writing it ourselves we'll
be using a special tool to create it so
we'll actually be working with much
simpler CSV or comma separated values
data and will let open ai's tool do to
the heavy lifting now as well as wanting
Json L format open AI gives us some
further criteria for the format of our
data it wants each prompt to end with a
separator to show where the prompt ends
and the completion begins it wants each
completion to start with a white space
add it once each completion to end with
a stop sequence to inform the model
where the completion ends now the stop
sequence is something that we haven't
needed yet but we will talk about it
when we get to that point in the project
and everything will become clear to be
honest all of this sounds like a bit of
a pain and actually in their example
data they didn't even show us exactly
what they wanted with these stop
sequences and the separator so we don't
even have that to help us but good news
is right here you can use our CLI data
preparation tool to easily convert your
data into this format so we're going to
let that tool do everything for us so
don't worry at all if that looks
intimidating okay in the next Grim let's
take a look at the data we'll be using
okay let's take a look at the data we're
going to use now writing Json out by
hand is a pain so I've organized this in
a spreadsheet using comma separated
values or CSV all we've got here is two
columns prompt and completion each
prompt is a question from a customer and
each completion is an answer from
customer service so we've just got two
columns I think we can work with that
and I've got 38 pairs of prompts and
completions ideally I would have 10
times that number or even more but this
small data set is going to allow us to
see the principle of how fine tuning
works now I've also pasted the CSV data
into this file right here and it doesn't
look like it's formatted but actually
CSV formatting is really simple we've
got the two column headings right here
and then each line contains one prompt
completion pair so this is the prompt
right here and this is the completion
after the comma now I just want to draw
your attention to the last few pairs
because here I've done something which
is just a little bit more complex it's a
little bit tricky to see so I'm just
going to take this last prompt
completion pair and space it out a
little bit now instead of just having
one question and one answer the prompt
actually consists of several parts the
first part is a summary then we've
actually got a short conversation so
we've got something that the customer
has asked and then we've got the agents
reply and then the customer has
responded to the agent and then we
finish with the agent and a space and
then we get the completion at the very
end so basically all of that is the
prompt and that is the completion now
I've done that just to show you that
these prompts don't have to just be one
question and one answer they can't
actually involve lots and lots of
dialogue so if you have got a lot of
customer service data you can format it
in this way with the completion just
being the final answer to the query and
that is going to really help train your
chat Bots now you don't need to stick to
one data style as long as you're working
with prompts and completions you can mix
as I've done here some of the prompts
will be one question and some of the
prompts will actually be whole
conversations okay let me just put this
data back as it was
now as we're going to be working with
this data in the terminal you need to
download it or have some data of your
own in a similar format you can download
it just by clicking on this slide and
that's going to take you through to a
Google Sheets version which you can save
a local copy of or you can come down
here to this Cog icon and when you click
on that it will bring up a menu and
click downloader zip which will give you
a zipped folder and when you unzip it
you'll see all of the files from this
project the one you're interested in of
course is the we Wing It data CSV so I'm
going to take that file and save it in
my apps folder in a file called we wing
it and there we are there is my data
ready for the next step okay we've got
some work to do with this data before we
can actually upload it and fine-tune a
model we are going to use open ai's data
preparation tool to do that for us but
before we can do that we need to set up
our command line interface environment
so next let's open up the terminal and
tackle that
for the next part of the project we're
going to be using the terminal or
command prompt if you're new to using
the terminal it can look pretty
intimidating it's actually not that bad
and to help you along I've created a
file over here called terminal
commands.md and I've pasted in all of
the commands we're using in this scrim
so you can refer to that quickly and
easily if you need to now to open the
command prompt in Windows you can use
the Windows key plus s and enter CMD in
the search field on MacBook it should be
right there in the launcher and of
course in either case you could use the
terminal in vs code now I've got the
terminal open and the open AI tool that
we're going to use requires python 3.
now if you've already got Python 3
installed then you're good to go if
you've never used python before and
you're starting to freak out don't worry
we're not coding in Python it's just
needed in the background to run open
ai's tools now you can check to see if
you've got Python 3 installed with this
command Bond so it's just Python 3 dash
dash version and when I hit enter it
tells me that I've got python 311.1 now
if you haven't got python installed you
can click on this slide and that is
going to take you to the official python
site or if you're on Mac you can use
Homebrew or if you're on Linux you can
probably get python from your distros
repository check their docs for details
now in a moment we're also going to need
the PIP package manager if you have
python installed you probably already
have Pip and you can check by doing pip
dash dash version and that tells me that
I have got pip installed if for some
reason you haven't got pip installed
this Command right here python3 Dash M
ensure pip dash dash upgrade will
install the latest version okay now we
should be good to go so let's install
the open AI CLI using pip install dash
dash upgrade open AI that should install
the open AI tool and you can check that
by running the open AI command and that
should give you a list of commands that
are specific to this open AI tool now
there's one more thing I want to do the
fine tune model we create is going to be
specific to us only we can use it so the
open AI tool will need our API key we
don't need that to prepare the data but
we will need it before we upload so we
might as well do it right now you can
add the open AI key with this command
it's basically export and then
everything that we've got in this m.js
file in this line of code right here but
be sure to swap out this colon for an
equals now when you've done that press
enter and you're not going to get any
special acknowledgment that your keys
been accepted just assume it has been
and now with all of that set up complete
we're ready to work with the data
separation tool so let's get stuck into
that next
Okay so we've got the open AI CLI up and
running and we've given it our API key
now let's use it to prepare our data and
again I've listed the CLI commands that
I'm going to use in this file right here
so our first task is to CD to the folder
where we've stored our data now I've
saved my data in a folder called we Dash
wing it in apps which is in documents so
let's head back to the terminal and I'm
going to say CD documents slash apps
slash we Dash Wing It CD here stands for
change directory and of course you'll
need to navigate to wherever it is you
saved your data file okay having
navigated to the correct folder we can
start our fine tune preparation so we do
that with this command and what we're
doing here is telling the terminal to
use the open AI fine tunes tool to
prepare our data now this F flag is
going to identify the file of data that
we want to prepare now my day data was
called we Dash wingit
data.csv so what I need to do is just
put that right there on the end now at
this point you might run into a problem
the first few times I did this it worked
fine and then suddenly at this point I
started to hit an error well that's the
nature of working with new technology
things can change and the error I got
was this missing pandas well if open AI
wants pandas open AI gets pandas so what
you need to do then is say pip install
open AI pandas once you've done that hit
enter let it do its thing and then we
can try the data preparation task once
again so this is the exact same command
this time it works and it gives us some
information it knows our file is
formatted as a CSV file it also
complains about the number of prompt
completion pairs we're using and says in
general we recommend having at least a
few hundred examples well we know that
already but this is for good
demonstration purposes so it's
absolutely fine now I'm going to save
you reading the rest of this text here
because actually it's telling us
something we already know we talked
about the format of our data and all of
the features that we need and we know
that we need a separator to inform the
model when the prompt ends and the
completion begins we know that each
completion needs to start with a single
white space and we know that each
completion should end with a stop
sequence to inform the model when the
completion has ended but this tool is
great because it's basically going to do
everything for us so down at the bottom
it's already told us that it's necessary
to convert this to Json L that's
absolutely fine it's recommending us to
add a suffix separator to all of our
prompts well let's say yes to that now
it's recommending adding a suffix ending
of a new line character to all of the
completions let's say yes to that and
press enter and now it's recommending us
to add a white space character to the
beginning of all of the completions
again let's say yes
now we just need to confirm that we're
ready to proceed and it goes through its
process and it tells us that it has
created this file for us and it invites
us to take a look which is a really good
idea if you go back to your folder
wherever you stored your data you should
see this prepared Json L file waiting
for you now just so we can see this data
I'm going to copy it into a file in the
editor and there we are and you can see
that it's added the prompt key and
completion key to each pair it's added
white space before the start of every
completion it's added a new line
character at the end of every completion
and of course it's added a separator at
the end of every prompt and we could
have done all of that by hand and just
used the tool to check but wow what a
lot of boring work that would have been
okay next we need to fine-tune our data
so let's come on to that in the next
scrim
okay let's get to work on the fine tune
at the end of the data preparation
process we got this instruction so let's
just break down what that is telling us
to do firstly we're using the open AI
CLI tool to access the API then we need
to use this fine tunes.create command
and we use the T flag here to introduce
our training data and we saved that in a
file called we Dash Wing It Dash data
underscore
prepared.json L our training data which
has been prepared into the Json L format
now we need to add just a little bit
more to the end the docs tell us that we
can use an m flag to specify the base
model to use and we're going to use the
DaVinci model if we leave that blank it
will actually default to the older Curie
model okay let's put that command in the
terminal and when I press enter we get
this message now open AI needs to Inc
cue this and it takes some time the
quickest for me has been a few minutes
the longest was literally all night now
down here it says stream interrupted
client disconnected that is really
common it doesn't mean that the fine
tune process has stopped it just means
that open AI is no longer giving us live
updates and what we can do is take this
command here paste it and run it and
that will reconnect us to the
information stream and eventually we'll
get this message with an emoji that
tells us we have been successful and
then what we see down here is actually
our very own fine-tuned model it's
everything from DaVinci right up until
the date now that's pretty cool but
before we can use that model in our app
we need to make some changes to our
JavaScript so let's go ahead and do that
next
okay so to use this model we need to
update our existing code the first thing
to remember here is that we have
fine-tuned a DaVinci based model and at
the time of recording you can't fine
tune gpt4 that means that we need to get
rid of loads of this specific format now
I've divided this process into several
parts and we'll have challenges for them
over several scrims the first task is to
change this array which is holding the
conversation DaVinci models just need a
string holding the conversation and we
won't be using an instruction here are
two mini challenges to do just that
firstly change conversation array to
conversation string and you can
initialize it to an empty string now
I've just put a warning here think about
how this is going to work is there any
other change you need to make I'm just
going to let you think about that once
you've done that you can come down here
and update conversation string with just
the user's input so instead instead of
pushing this whole object all we
actually want to push is whatever the
user has inputted then you can just log
out conversation string to check it's
working and I've disabled the fetch
reply function as at the moment we just
get an error if we sent off the string
instead of the array of objects to the
current endpoint that we've got in our
code right here okay pause now take all
the time you need and I'll see you back
here in just a moment
okay hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so let's just delete
everything we've got here we're going to
make this conversation string I'm just
using the abbreviation Str and we'll
initialize that to an empty string next
we need to come down here and update
conversation string with just the user's
input so again we need to convert
conversation array to conversation
string and instead of push we can just
use plus equals
and let's log out conversation string
and hit save okay I'll just type
something in the Box
and look we get an error and it's a type
error assignment to constant variable
well I did warn you here think about how
this is going to work is there any other
change you need to make well yes we need
to change this const for alert
let's try again
and there we are it is working so that
is two of the jobs off the list let's
move on to what happens inside the fetch
reply function
next up we need to change the end point
create chat completion is specific to
models like gpt4 we are going back to
the completions endpoint which uses
create completion so I'm just going to
come in here and delete chat now for
your challenge I want you to swap out
the model gpt4 for your fine-tuned model
and you can get the model name from
right at the end of the fine tune
process now if you've closed your
terminal window don't worry log in to
open ai go to the playground come up
here to where we've got model and just
click this down arrow that will bring up
a list of all the regular models and
also all of the fine-tune models that
you have created now for the second part
of the challenge our fine tune model
needs a property called prompt not
messages so you just need to swap out
messages for prompt and you also need to
update this reference to conversation
array conversation array does not exist
anymore once you've done that you can
run a test by logging out the response
now before you do the challenge I'm just
going to uncomment this fetch reply
function call and I have already
commented out these two lines of code
when we've got the endpoint working
properly we'll uncomment them and make
some adjustments okay pause now get this
challenge sorted and I'll see you back
here in just a moment
okay hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so I'm going to come down here
and I'm going to just grab the name of
my fine tune model and I've got it right
here and I just need to paste it right
here next this messages property needs
to become prompt
and conversation array needs to become
conversation string okay let's log out
the response and see what we get and I'm
just going to hit save and ask a random
question in here
let's open up the console and see what
we get and there we are we've got a
response and the response is a little
bit strange I'm just going to copy it
into the editor so you can see it
clearly
the response to my question how are you
today was bizarrely
this
it sounds like you've been on a real
roller coaster I'm sorry well that's
okay we've still got quite a long way to
go before we get this fine tune chatbot
working so it doesn't matter at all that
it's giving us quite a random answer the
important thing is we're managing to
make an API call to this new model and
we're getting a response so in the next
Grim let's get to work on these two
lines of code right here
we need to make a few more changes to
the JavaScript before we can do some
testing so at the moment in these two
commented lines of code we are pushing
to the old conversation array and we're
also sending our completion to render
typewriter text those two lines of code
are not going to work anymore we need to
make some changes so firstly let's
uncomment this line of code and we'll
change this to conversation string and
instead of using push we will of course
use plus equals
and what is it that we need to update
conversation string with well I've just
pasted in the response that we got up
here and it's pretty similar to the
responses we were getting when we were
using the chat GPT models now if we look
down here this one ends with messages
messages doesn't exist we've got choices
but the completion is actually stored in
text so let's just change message for
text
and of course we don't need these
brackets and now that we're updating
conversation string just with the
completion we can actually reuse this
code here because we also need to send
the completion to render typewriter text
so let's just paste that in here and now
it should work so I'm just going to
delete a couple of console.logs
and let's delete all of this ugly code
as well and give it a test
and okay it's working and it said I've
got some lovely things for sale in my
shop I hope you like now the reason why
it's finished on like with no
punctuation is because now we're using a
DaVinci model again we need to set max
tokens at the moment it is set to 16 by
default let's set it to something much
higher
and I'm just going to try that again
wow and now it's gone a little bit crazy
all I said was hey there and it's given
us all of this stuff which is sort of
related to the data we uploaded it
certainly got the email address right
and it's given us some rather random
phone numbers although this one is not
too far away from the one we told it
about and then it starts going on about
using cookies on the website well this
is more than just hallucination it's
actually gone a bit crazy and what's
worse is that it still didn't finish on
a complete sentence so if we whacked Max
tokens up to something much higher like
a thousand I've got a feeling that this
crazy chat bot would go on and on but
hey ho at least it's working the basic
mechanics are fine so in the next Grim
let's start figuring out what's going
wrong
so we have the fine tune chatbot working
or sort of because actually it's giving
us nonsensical gibberish so let's just
check the settings we have the presence
penalty and frequency penalty aren't
doing anything very much they're almost
at their default so I'm not too worried
about them now with open AI when the
completions are a bit weird the first
thing we might think of is temperature
remember temperature controls how daring
the model will be how creative how
inventive now we don't want creative we
want factual so let's put the
temperature down to zero
and let's see if that has had any effect
okay that completion is like something
from a horror movie now the chatbot is
claiming to be a human it's begging us
not to kill it and it's just saying
please please please and then creating a
word so long it actually breaks our CSS
so I'm just going to refresh to get rid
of that because it's just a bit scary
okay so the temperature hasn't magically
solved the problem but I think a low
temperature will be useful so I'm going
to leave it there now before we do
anything else let's go back to the
criteria for the format of our data the
first one that we had says each prompt
ends with a separator to inform the
model when the prompt ends and the
completion begins and actually when we
were prepping the data it told us that
it would use this Arrow as the separator
so what we need to do is add the
separator to the end of our prompt and
I've got the Json L file right here and
we can see that each prompt does indeed
end with a space and an arrow separator
now we're not adding those separators to
our conversation string and I think that
might be causing part of the problem so
in fact I'm just going to log out
conversation string right here
and let's be brave and just see if the
chatbot is going to scare us again
and it's done the same creepy thing
again now let's just have a quick look
down in the console and what we can see
there if I just cut and paste it into
the editor is that we're just getting
one continuous line of text
so hey and I'm not a robot look like
they're being said by the same speaker
but in fact that was our prompt and this
is the beginning of the completion so we
have got problems there and that brings
us to a challenge and your challenge is
this I want you to add the arrow
separator to the end of our prompt as it
is added to conversation string and I've
put here a space before the arrow
separator because that is how it's
formatted in our Json L data okay I'm
going to leave the console.log that I
just added so when you're done with this
you can just type something into the
chat bot and give it a test pause now
get that sorted and I'll see you back
here in just a minute
okay hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so I want to come down here
and put this in backticks
and now we'll use the dollar sign and
the curly braces
so we can access the user input.value
I'm going to start with a space
and I'm going to end with a space and an
arrow separator
okay let's give that a try
Okay so we've seen an improvement there
this is by no means perfect but at least
it's working a little bit now it feels
like we're talking to a representative
of the wee Wing It company it's got the
email address it's still giving us a
load of hallucination and weirdness and
if we look down in the console we have
at least got our separator between hey
which was our prompt and odia which was
the beginning of the completion so we've
made some small progress here but what
else could be going wrong let's just go
back to our data formatting criteria
so we've sorted the first one secondly
it says each completion should start
with a single white space well if we
have a look down in the console that
appears to be true or is it I think the
next thing that we should do is come
down here to fetch reply and where we're
updating conversation string with the
completion we should explicitly add a
white space at the beginning so again
I'm going to put this in backticks
use the dollar sign and curly braces to
access the completion from the response
and now I'll add my white space at the
beginning okay let's hit save and try
that one more time
and that's not really made any
Improvement I think that's just as crazy
as it was before but we have now got
that white space there for sure we know
it's there we've ruled that out as a
potential cause of problems so let's go
back to the data criteria and look at
the third one each completion should end
with a stop sequence to inform the model
when the completion ends well we're back
with the mysterious stop sequence we
keep coming across it and we've never
really looked at it in detail so why
don't we deal with that next
let's take a look at these stop sequence
a way of stopping the model from
generating tokens so what exactly is it
and how does it work well it's an
optional setting that tells the API to
stop generating tokens at a given point
the completion will never contain the
stop sequence and this stop sequence is
an array and that's because we can have
multiple stops in a stop sequence now
all of that is quite theoretical so
let's just jump straight into an example
and you'll see what I mean right here
I've got a basic API request setup using
the text DaVinci 003 model and I'm just
asking it to list some great books to
read on the topic of coding so I will
uncomment this function call and hit
save and let's open up the console and
see what we get and there we are we get
10 good book recommendations now I'm
going to come in here underneath the max
tokens and I'm going to add a stop
sequence and the property that we want
is just stop the stop sequence is an
array and each individual stop will be a
string now we can have up to four stops
in this array I'm only going to use one
and if we look at the formatting of
what's in the console each list item
starts with a number and a DOT so it's
one dot code the hidden language of
computer hardware and software by
Charles petzold two dot python crash
course by Eric maths so the stop that I
put in here just to experiment with is
going to be two dots let's see what
happens when I press save
we get a list with only one item so what
happened here well if you remember the
completion will not contain the stop
sequence so the model was prevented from
writing two dots and because it won't
write a stop sequence at that point the
completion is cut off so if we wanted a
list of five books we could change this
to six Dot and there we are we have got
a list of five books now you can use
anything as a stop you can put whatever
characters in there you might find in
your completion but you just need to
know what you're doing with it obviously
if you put something like the letter A
well that's going to cause all sorts of
problems
there we are the completion has actually
been cut off on the fourth letter of the
book title which was obviously an a now
when we're working with chat Bots it's
very common to use the new line value as
a stop sequence why because often you
want the bot to give you one paragraph
as an answer and then you want the user
to respond if you don't use a stop
sequence with a chat bot you run the
risk of the chatbot answering and asking
questions and having a conversation with
itself that becomes ever more bizarre
and illogical until it hits the token
limit and that stops IT now with the
general purpose chat bot we built with
gpt4 we didn't need to add a stop
property because gpt4 has actually got
that specific syntax the object with the
role and the content properties DaVinci
and other models don't have that so we
can use the new line character as a stop
to stop the bot from continuing the
conversation on its own okay let's go
back to the app and add a stop property
okay so if we refer back to our slide we
can see that each completion should end
with a stop sequence to inform the model
when the completion ends and when we
were preparing our data we actually
selected this option to add a suffix
ending of a new line character which is
backslash n so as we add completions to
our conversation we need to include this
new line character at the end as a stop
sequence now we're also using this Arrow
as a separator and when experimenting
with this I sometimes found arrows
popping up in completions and some cases
where the chatbot seem to just get into
a conversation with itself asking itself
questions and giving itself answers so
we're actually going to add the arrow as
a stop sequence as well because we never
want the model to generate an arrow okay
so here is your challenge and it comes
in two parts firstly I want you to add
the new line character which is
backslash n and the separator as a stop
sequence and actually you don't need to
have a space in the stop sequence
secondly I've said here I want you to
add something to the line below where we
update conversation string so that is
this line of code right here I'm going
to leave you to think about that what
would it be good to add to that line
okay pause now get that challenge sorted
and I'll see you back here in just a
moment
okay so hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so let's come in here and
we'll add our stop and we know that that
will be an array and it will be an array
of strings so the first string is going
to be the new line character
and the second string will be the arrow
separator
and of course it doesn't matter what
order they go in now the Second
Challenge adds something to the line
below where we update conversation
string well if we refer back to this
slide we're going to add a suffix ending
of backslash n to all completions so
this is the completion that we're
getting back let's just add a new line
character to the end of that and what
that is going to do is make it really
clear to the model when it reads
conversation string that it has reached
the end of a completion because that is
what the new line character will tell it
and likewise the arrow separator that
we're adding to the stop sequence here
which we're already adding to
conversation string right here in the
event listeners Anonymous function that
will tell the model that it's reached
the end of a prompt okay let's hit save
and see if it's worked so I'll start
again just by saying hey
all right and I'm still getting a pretty
strange response here now I'm going to
ask a question from our data and if we
have a quick look at the data we can see
that the customer support team has a
phone number so I'm going to ask it what
is your phone number
okay and look we're getting a much
better quality response it knows the
phone number it is still hallucinating
we're only here from 9 to 6 30 weekdays
that is not actually true but the answer
is much shorter and it's much more
manageable now I'm going to ask it a
question it can't know the answer to
because it simply isn't in the data
I'll ask it who is your CEO
okay interesting it completely makes up
a person Richard Queen so for some
reason the large language model has
decided that Richard quing is the most
probable name for a CEO of our company
and it's also made up an email address
for him but using at wewingit.com so
again it's a hallucination but it's an
interesting one so I think where we are
at the moment is that this chatbot works
it can see its data it's giving us short
manageable answers which makes sense but
we're still getting too many
hallucinations it is not accurate now we
are going to get hallucinations because
as I said at the beginning we're not
really using enough data we've got
enough data to show the principle but
not enough data for a full production
ready app but that said there is one
last really important aspect of fine
tuning that I want to tell you about and
it is an epochs what does that mean well
when we were building the model you
might have noticed that as the model was
fine-tuning it completed various epochs
and in this case it completed four
epochs well maybe four epochs just
wasn't enough so in the next Grim let's
talk about what epochs are how we can
get more of them and how that is going
to help us so let's check that out next
let's talk about an epochs and I've put
here the number of data Cycles so what
exactly are an epochs well the n stands
for number so it's the number of epochs
and what that basically means is that it
controls the number of times open AI
will cycle through the training data set
when fine-tuning the model now it
defaults to four and that is likely fine
for larger data sets with hundreds or
thousands of prompt completion pairs but
for smaller data sets it isn't enough
the disadvantage of using higher numbers
and therefore more Cycles through the
training data is that it costs more to
do the fine tune with a small data set
like ours it's still going to be pretty
cheap the other thing to think about is
that if you're using a massive data set
it will take a long time now an epochs
is something we set when we send the
training data to be fine-tuned we can't
set it from within our app so what we
need to do is go back to the CLI and
we're going to add this to the the end
of the fine tuning command it's just
dash dash n underscore epochs and then
the number of epochs you want and I'm
going to go for 16. you don't have to go
for 16 but I got much improved results
using 16. you could go higher but just
remember it costs more each time so that
is the same command we used before
here's the N epochs added on the end and
so the final command will look like this
is everything we did before plus this an
epochs on the end with the Double Dash
so here is a challenge for you use open
AI CLI tool to build a new fine-tuned
model with an epochs set to 16. you
don't need to prepare the data again
that command is all you need once you've
gone through that process you will get a
new model name and you can slide it in
right here replacing the old model once
you've done that go ahead and test it by
asking it about whiming its phone number
or email or anything else from the data
that we've got right here go ahead and
do that it won't take very long at all
to set up it might take quite a while
for the API to actually do the fine
tuning process so make yourself a cup of
tea and we'll have a look at this
together when it's done
okay hopefully you got some good results
with that so I'm going to come over to
the terminal there is the command to
create the fine tune I'm going to add
the N Epoch 16 on the end and press
enter and then eventually having gone
through its process it's completed all
of these epochs down to 16 and finally I
have got my new model and here it is
right here so let's go ahead and swap
the old model for the new model
okay let's hit save and do some testing
so I'm going to start off asking about
the phone number
okay and that is a really nice answer
it's got the phone number correct and
it's also said we prefer it if you only
phone Us in an emergency now that's
really interesting because if we look at
the data
we mentioned the phone number several
times if we come down to line 19 well we
can see here we've got the
straightforward question what is your
phone number and if I just move the mini
browser out of the way it does actually
say we prefer it if people only phone Us
in an emergency and it gives exactly the
same times as the chat bot told us right
here so the chat bot is successfully
using our data and that is really really
good and it's also suggested they email
us instead okay now I want to ask it
something it can't know the answer to
who is your CEO in the previous scrim it
hallucinated an answer to this so let's
see what it does
who is your CEO
and it says I'm sorry I don't know the
names of the people working here now
that's really interesting I've made sure
to include in this data various I don't
know statements if we have a look right
here on line 18 for example what
material are your drones made of
completion I don't know the answer to
that question check out line 24 who is
your press officer I'm sorry I don't
know the names of members of staff and
again on line 32 we have are your drones
recyclable I'm really sorry I don't know
the answer to that question now
traditionally AI is not very good at
saying I don't know it prefers to
hallucinate but we've effectively given
it permission to do that so do bear that
in mind when working with chatbot data
it's good to teach it to say I don't
know as this will help stop it
hallucinating let's just ask a few more
questions so I'm going to say how much
is insurance
and it's telling me it's three pounds 75
per delivery and if I come up onto Line
eight well there we are it says it's a
flat rate of 3 pound 75 per drone order
so again that is pretty good let's ask
it something a little bit more random
I've said your drone crashed into my
house
okay it says please contact us by email
and we'll arrange to pay for any damage
I'm going to say I want compensation
and there we are it's giving a very
logical rational answer now it's not
being particularly Humane it's not being
touchy-feely it's not being that
conversational and that to be honest is
a shortcoming of our data we just need
much much more data and we need much
more of this kind of data that we've got
at the bottom where we've got these
entire conversations playing out before
we get to the completion because that is
the quality data that's what really
helps the chat bot communicate well
so although I think we've done very well
here you will find limitations with this
chat bot quite quickly you're going to
come across idiosyncrasies and
hallucinations but as I've said many
times if you wanted to take this to
production you would need a lot more
data but what we've done here has really
proved the principle it's working really
well on a really small data set so that
is really good and of course your
results might differ perhaps you're
using your own data or perhaps the model
has simply been updated somewhat between
the time that this was recorded and the
time that you're actually building this
app and that is the nature of working
with this new frontier in technology now
the next thing that I want to do is take
this app and deploy it live on the
internet with the API key safely hidden
that's quite a process we've got quite a
bit to do so let's make a start next
okay so our mission is to deploy our
support bot but keep the API key hidden
and we're going to do this using netlify
so right now if we were just to deploy
this as a front-end only project the API
key would be visible right there on
every user's machine and easily
obtainable from the devtools network tab
let's just zoom in oops there it is our
API key is there for all to see and that
is what we need to avoid what we want is
for you to be able to share the projects
you've made with open AI without fear of
your key being compromised and actually
the process we're about to go through
can be used anytime you need to keep an
API key hidden it's not specific to open
AI in any way
so how are we going to do this well
let's take a high level overview now at
the moment we've got a front-end project
and what we've been doing is storing the
API key on the front end making a
request to the open AI API and getting
back a completion that we use on the
front end but now we're going to stop
doing that and do something completely
different we are going to send our
request to a netlify serverless function
the serverless function will have access
to the API key from a secure store the
serverless function will then make the
call to the open AI API the API will
pass the response back to the serverless
function and the serverless function
will pass the response back to the front
end and we'll use the completion from
that response but most importantly this
API key in its special store is never
visible to the front end so it won't be
visible in the devtools network tab now
there are a few prerequisites that I'll
just mention quick you are going to need
a free netlify account that's really
easy to get I'm also going to assume you
have a basic knowledge of GitHub because
we will be deploying to netlify directly
from GitHub if you know how to publish a
project to a GitHub repo that is enough
we'll also be making fetch requests and
if you followed this course so far you
won't have any problem with that we
won't really be doing anything more
sophisticated than we've already done
and you'll also need vs code or a
similar editor okay that's the overview
let's put it into practice
so firstly we need to get our project
stored locally so come down here and
click on this Cog icon and that will
bring up a menu click download a zip and
then unzip that folder and save it
somewhere sensible I've saved mine in
this folder called we Wing It underscore
deploy and it's inside another folder
called apps
now let's open that in vs code now
before we forget and to save us from
running into an error later I want to
open up index.js and come on to line two
we won't be importing the API key like
this anymore so let's go ahead and
delete that import statement if you skip
this step when we deploy the project to
netlify you will get an error and it
will be a bit frustrating so best to
remember to do it now next we need to
open up the terminal and I'll zoom in on
it and I'm going to run npm install and
this will download the dependencies
defined in the package.json file and it
will generate a node modules folder with
the installed modules the dependency
that we've been using is the open AI API
and we still need it when we deploy to
netlify okay we run that we let it do
its thing and then we can see that the
node modules folder has appeared the
next step is to publish to GitHub so
you're welcome to do this in whichever
way you're comfortable with I've got the
GitHub and pull requests extension in
installed so I will go with this icon
right here and I'm going to come down
here and click on publish to GitHub I'm
going to publish mine to a private
repository now it's asking me here which
files should be included in the
repository really important to ignore
the m.js file so I'll untick that now
you could also delete it it doesn't
matter if you delete it or ignore it
just make sure you don't include it in
your repo if you choose to delete it
make sure you've got a copy of it
somewhere handy as we will be using it
again shortly okay I'll click ok I'll
let vs code do its thing and then when
the process is completed we can see that
we've got the git ignore file and m.js
is in that file so that is exactly what
we want and of course at this point you
can log into GitHub and check it's
worked if you want to be sure okay so
we've got the project stored in a repo
we've either ignored or deleted the API
key next we need to set up a netlify
account
okay next up we need a netlify account
it's really easy to do click on this
slide and it's going to take you through
to the sign up page which looks like
this now I'm going to sign up with
GitHub and then once it's done its thing
it will take me to the dashboard and
from here I'm going to select add new
site I'll import an existing project and
it will invite me to connect to a git
provider I'll choose GitHub and it's
going to say no repositories found and
that's absolutely fine click configure
netlify on GitHub and this will open a
pop-up page and you can scroll down and
either select all repositories or select
repositories individually I'm going to
do that one and I'll choose the
repository I'll just type in we Wing It
underscore deploy because that's the
name of my repo and click save and will
be taken to a settings page and on here
we can leave everything as it is and
just scroll down to the bottom and click
on deploy site as the site deploys we
will see site deploy in progress right
here and then eventually published so
now the site is live we can click on
open production deploy and that is going
to actually take us to our site we've
got our own funky netlify URL right here
and let's see if it works so we can just
come down here type in a question press
send and we'll wait and nothing happens
let's open up devtools and we've got
plenty of Errors well that isn't
actually a problem we've only done the
first stage and actually it would be
really weird if it worked it doesn't
have an API key right now so our next
step is to get our API key to netlify
and we're going to store it in a netlify
environment variable let's come on to
that next
what we need to do now is give netlify
the API key now if you remember the
function that we'll be using to actually
do the heavy lifting of making the API
call will have special access to our API
key so on the netlify site come over
here to site settings and we're going to
click on environment variables and we
can click add a variable and then I'm
going to select add a single variable
that takes us to this page and we need
to add a key and a value so let's take a
look at our code right here because this
is essentially the same information this
is going to be our key and the actual
API key will be the value so back on
this form then we'll have open AI API
key in here and the actual API key
stored here as the value then click
create variable and we can see that the
open AI API key has been added so what
we've done here is we've stored our API
key in a netlify environment variable so
now if we scroll up and we launch our
site again we can try asking a question
but we're going to have the same result
we'll still get errors and that figures
netlify has the API key but we're not
doing anything with it in the code and
anyway at the moment all we've got is
our front-end code and if it did work
the API key would still be visible in
devtools the fact that we've stored in
an environment variable doesn't mean you
can't then display it on the front end
you actually can that is why we need the
serverless function to make the API call
away from the front end okay so what we
need to do next then is work on the
serverless function but in order to set
up a serverless function we need to get
Hands-On with the terminal again and
install netlifies CLI or command line
interface so let's do that next
okay so to integrate a serverless
function we need the netlify CLI so
let's come back to the terminal and just
to help out I've created a document here
called terminal commands.md and I've
just listed the terminal commands that
we'll be using in this scrim
so we're going to come in here with the
First Command which is install netlify
CLI Dash G so I'm installing this
globally that's what the dash g means so
we can hit enter and eventually you'll
get shown something like this now if we
just type netlify and hit enter we'll
get taken to a list of netlify commands
and the one that we're really interested
in is init for initialize and we're
going to use that to configure our site
so down here let's say netlify init and
now it's going to ask us a series of
questions the first one is connect this
directory to an existing netlify site
now we've got two options here and we
can just move up or down with the arrow
keys but the first option is the one we
want so I'll just press enter now it's
asking us if we want to use the current
git remote origin and it's correctly
identified the we Winger underscore
deploy repository that I'm using so
that's fine click enter and there we are
it says Direct Three Links that is what
we want to see and if we go back to the
full screen of vs code we've now got a
new DOT netlify folder okay in the next
Grim we'll use the CLI to give us the
boilerplate for a serverless function
okay let's get to work on a serverless
function the netlify CLI is going to
give us some boilerplate so in the
terminal let's say netlify functions
colon create we'll hit enter and we're
going to get some options the first one
is for an edge function we don't want
that so we can use the arrow key to come
down to serverless function press enter
and it's going to ask us a few questions
the language that we want is Javascript
so hit enter
now it's telling us to pick a template
and we've got some interesting options
here including this one or fetch which
talks about apis but because we've
already got the open AI dependency and
we're not really dealing with
authentication I'm going to go with this
basic hello world function and we're
going to adapt it from there so let's
hit enter now it's asking me for a name
the default is hello world we definitely
don't want that I'm going to go for
fetch AI which I think is a reasonably
descriptive name and the function is
instantly created and now if we look at
the whole of vs code we've got a new
folder here netlify let's click into it
here's our function fetch AI let's click
on that and there we are that is the
boilerplate for our serverless function
and at the moment it's basically
returning hello subject well we can see
from this line of code right here that
unless we put a query string parameter
in this subject will be world so this
should return hello world and if we open
up a browser and we actually navigate to
dot netlify functions slash the name of
our function and I have actually put
that right here in this terminal
commands MD file and when we go to that
URL what we get is this message hello
world so we're seeing the object
returned from that serverless function
and so this URL is now my endpoint this
is what I'm going to call from the front
end instead of calling the open AI API
directly so next we need to go back to
the editor and make some changes to
index.js we want to make it so that
instead of calling the open AI API
directly we make a fetch request to this
new endpoint so let's do that next
okay so we need to completely change
this fetch reply function so instead of
calling the open AI API directly from
the front end now we're going to call
the netlify serverless function now I'm
going to set you a challenge to update
fetch reply right here in the scrimber
editor but when we're done we're going
to need to paste this into vs code and
push it to GitHub to trigger a redeploy
first we need a URL to call and we've
already seen the URL we looked at it
before and I've got it right here in the
URL bar so I'm just going to come in
here and paste it in a const called URL
and now it's time for a challenge and it
is quite a long Challenge and this is
where I'm assuming you have some
knowledge of fetch requests but do take
all of the time you need and feel free
to search online if you need to when I
do this I'm going to use async await but
you don't have to you can use a fetch
request and chain then statements if you
prefer to do it that way
also I'm just going to comment these two
lines of code
when we've got this working in the
console we can uncomment these and
update them as needed but we'll do that
after we've got the serverless function
working properly okay let's check out
the challenge
so I want you to make a fetch request to
the URL that we've got saved here using
the following details the method should
be Post in the headers the content type
should be Text slash plane and the body
should hold conversation string which
remember we have got stored right here
now once you've made the effect request
you can save the response to a const and
log it out then copy and paste the
updated fetch reply function to vs code
and delete any unnecessary code from
index.js push the changes to GitHub to
trigger a redeploy and remember that
will take some seconds maybe as long as
a minute and then navigate to your
netlify site put something in the text
input it doesn't actually matter what
because it's not going to be rendered
and it's not going to be sent to open AI
hit send and then what you should see in
the console is hello world and that will
show that from the front end we're
successfully managing to access the
serverless function and get whatever it
returns fans okay quite a lot to do so
pause now take all of the time you need
and we'll have a look together in just a
moment
okay so hopefully you managed to do that
just fine so I'm going to come down here
and I'm going to set up a new const
response
and I'm going to await a fetch request
the first thing a fetch request needs is
a URL well we've got that saved right
here
and now we need to pass it an object so
we've got all of the details here
firstly the method should be post
and then we need some headers
and this will hold an object and it's
going to have a single key value pair
the key will be content type
and the value will be Text slash plane
lastly it needs a body
and the body will hold conversation
string
okay then I'm going to come underneath
that and set up a const called Data
and we will await the response Json
and let's just log out data
now we've got plenty of code here that
we don't need all of this code down here
we can safely delete but I'm just going
to comment it out because we will need
to copy and paste it later and likewise
right up at the top all of this code
that brings in open AI we no longer need
and I will comment it out then I'm going
to copy the fetch reply function and I'm
going to bring it over to vs code and
I'm going to paste it in and of course I
haven't copied over the code I commented
out apart from these two lines which we
will be using here in the future now
staying in vs code up at the top we've
got these lines of code here we can
delete them when you've done that you
can save push it to GitHub and that will
trigger a netlify redeploy and remember
that will take a few seconds maybe even
a couple of minutes when it's done
navigate to our site send a message and
then what you see in the console should
be the object with hello world and that
will show you that the front end code
has successfully communicated with the
serverless function and that means we
need to get to work on this serverless
function next
I've just pasted this serverless
function into the scrimber editor and
again when we're done it will need to go
back into vs code so it can be pushed to
GitHub to trigger a redeploy now before
we do anything else let's delete all of
the code we don't need
okay that is the bare bones of the
serverless function now what we've got
at the end might look a little bit
unfamiliar don't worry about that that
is just exporting this Handler function
to make it available to the rest of the
app and that syntax there is actually
from node.js so it's not familiar to
front-end developers the next thing to
do is bring in open Ai and remember we
used npm install to load in the
dependencies we need so we have access
to them across our project including in
this serverless function now the code we
need to do that is code we're very
familiar with in fact we just commented
it out in index.js so let's head over to
index.js and let's uncomment that
now we will not be importing our API key
from this m.js file remember we've
ignored that or deleted it it's not
available on netlify so let's delete
that line of code
now the API key that we've got stored in
the netlify environment variable is
available to us in this serverless
function and we can access it using
process.m and then the name of the API
key so luckily we don't need to change
this line of code at all because this is
going to fetch our API key from the
environment variable we set up earlier
so now we've brought in open AI we need
to actually use it down here inside the
try block so let's head back to index.js
and we'll take the second block of code
that we've got commented out right here
that is looking pretty good but we need
to do something with conversation string
we don't have access to conversation
string in this file and we can't just
import it as this serverless function
will not be part of the front-end code
remember we're actually calling the
serverless function using a fetch
request and we've got the fetch request
right here and conversation string is
being sent in the body of the fetch
request now back in Fetch AI we're
taking in an event parameter and from
that event parameter we can actually
access the body so I'm going to come
down here and replace conversation
string with event dot body
so now when the fetch request comes in
the conversation string will be in the
body fetch AI takes in the event
parameter and accesses conversation
string which will be stored in the body
of the event object
okay I think that's looking good we
can't test it yet because first we need
to deal with what we actually get back
from the API we've got this return down
here so we need to do something with
that let's come on to it in the next
scrim
now we need to deal with what the
serverless function gets back from the
open AI API now that's no problem we've
worked with the API long enough by now
to know that what we get back is a
response object and that we need the
data from it
so working down here inside the return
statement and we've got the body we're
calling json.stringify and then in here
I've pasted a challenge for you I want
you to add a key value pair the key
should be reply and the value should be
response dot data
now once you've done that paste the code
into fetchai.js in vs code and push it
to GitHub to redeploy and see what gets
logged out when you test okay pause now
get that sorted and I'll see you back
here in just a moment
okay so all I need to do is come in here
and add the key value pair so the key is
reply
and the value is response dot data
okay let's copy that and I'm going to
paste it over here in vs code and I've
just formatted it a little bit more
neatly and obviously without the
challenge text now I'll go through the
process we've gone through several times
I'm going to push it all up to GitHub
and wait for the redeploy when the
redeploy is complete I'm going to
navigate to the site I'm just going to
say hey and then what we see in the
console is the data from the response
object and look what we've got here a
completion hi there how can I help you
okay that is big progress we have just
got one more step to take where we take
this completion and get it rendered
let's do that next
okay so the last thing that we need to
do is deal with these two lines of code
so let's go straight in to a challenge I
want you to update the two commented
lines of code to get this working once
you've done that you can push to GitHub
to redeploy and then test now when this
was purely a front-end project we were
taking our completion from the response
now we've got the response stored in
data so it's just a question of working
out where you get the completion from
within the data object okay pause now
get it sorted and we'll have a look
together in just a moment
okay hopefully you got that working just
fine now these lines of code are almost
correct but now we have this data object
and what we want is stored in the reply
so I'm going to delete response Dot
and let's go for data dot reply
dot choices and everything else can stay
the same
okay let's copy that over to vs code and
I'll just update these two lines right
here then we'll push to GitHub to
trigger a redeploy and I'll ask the
chatbot a question we get back a
completion it's looking good it's
working and best of all when we open up
the network tab there is absolutely no
sign of our API key so there we are we
have successfully deployed our open AI
project to the live internet with the
API key hidden and now you can safely
share your projects and use them in your
portfolio without fear of your API key
being compromised now you might be
thinking wait there anyone can just
access my serverless function they can
write their own fetch request to the URL
which of course is available on the
front end and then from there they'll be
able to use and abuse my open AI API key
well they can't this endpoint is only
going to accept fetch requests from its
own domain now we and prove that right
here in scrimber because if we want to
make a fetch request to this endpoint
right here from inside a scrim that
should not be possible because scrims
are hosted on scrimmer.com and this
endpoint is using my custom netlify URL
okay let's hit save and I'm going to
open up the console and I'll just say
hey
and there we are we get an error we are
not able to make a fetch request to that
URL from within scrimber.com and you can
repeat that test from your own domain
check out the dev tools and look in
detail at the error you get now of
course if for some reason we wanted
other domains to be able to access our
endpoint we would be able to do that
with the cause policy cause is the
cross-origin resource sharing and it is
quite a big topic but if it's completely
unfamiliar to you I do recommend you
read up on it at some point because it
is really important when you start
working with apis and endpoints okay we
are done with this project let's just
take one more scrim to recap what we've
studied and talk about where you go next
I just want to say massive
congratulations on finishing this course
you now have the AI foundations you need
to tackle almost any web dev related AI
task let's just have a quick look back
at what we've studied so we looked at
how to use the open AI API
we used various models including the
gpt4 model text DaVinci 003 and our own
fine-tuned model we looked at prompt
engineering including the zero shot
approach the few shot approach and the
specific object syntax needed for the
create chat completions endpoint we
worked on building chat Bots and on
fine-tuning a model using our own data
so the chatbot gave us answers specific
to our circumstances and of course along
the way we've had loads of challenges so
where next for you and AI well it would
be great to fine-tune with more data you
could get a fine-tuned bot production
ready now that will require you to find
and organize a lot of data also keep an
eye on the AI scene there is a lot going
on with text and images as we've seen
here but also with voice and of course
with video and in terms of how you use
that in your personal projects I
recommend you find a need for AI and
then build an app so work on something
that you've identified as a problem that
needs solving and use AI to solve it the
best portfolio projects are unique to
you now whatever you do why not head
over to scrimbers Discord server and go
to the today I did Channel this
screenshot is actually a link it will
take you straight there and you can let
everybody know that you finished the
course and tell them how you got on and
when it comes to stretch goals and your
own projects why not share them in the I
built this Channel show off your work
and get great feedback from your peers
and lastly do let me know how you got on
with the course and show me what
projects you've built you can catch me
right here on Twitter and all that
remains to be said is thank you very
much for completing this course and I
wish you all the very best